suppress, suppress. Don't let them breathe. Don't let them breathe.
Right? And and and so they're helping Fuentes and beyond Fuentes
more than they realize. So that's one path to fascism. The other
path is the path we're on now. >> This is the like the
establishment. >> I like Chank, but holy, that's uh Oh,
man. I like Chank, but I do feel like this is the definition
of useful idiot. Like unfortunately, it's like the extreme the
most extreme example I've ever seen of useful idiot in my life.
The one time of the year that the haters and enjoyers of a zomber
can come together and enjoy the same segment. Okay?
Cuz Chank always gets his licks in. Chank always eats in this,
but Hassan gets some licks in, too. It's always content.
If you hate Hassan, you get to see him get embarrassed on some
points and get kneelled on by Chenk. And if you love Hassan,
then you just get to watch him have like a passionate debate
with his uncle. All right? And his uncle's always had at least
two or three siders by the time he shows up in Hassan's room.
That's maybe the best part. That's what I love about Chanks Giving.
Could you imagine Shanks Giving if Chank was
Dude, Chanks Giving is Sank Chank Sank Chank getting hammered
and then coming in and just screaming at Hassan about stuff.
And I wouldn't have it any other
No, I couldn't possibly have it any other way. All right. I hate
all of them. I am not like you. Very cool, man. Very cool.
>> You're You're radical. All right.
>> Let's give it a look. Let's see. Let's
>> Hold on. Hassan's reading something here. He's We're
We're moments away. We're moments away. >> Well, here we
go. >> Aka Shaky Ga. >> Dude. Dude, there's something
to be said for Okay, I think Malta is very Turkish, right? There's
a lot of Turks in Malta.
Bro, can we get a DNA similarity test on Perry and the [__]
lineage? Okay, cuz that waddle is the same waddle. It's the same
one.
Look, I I'm I'm picturing Perry waddling in off at a camera onto
Aiden's stream. It's like the same one. On that note,
>> Unk Chunk Wigger aka Shaky Gurga. >> Let's go.
[laughter] I can You can tell by the waddle, by the way. You
can just tell by the waddle that he has had a couple drinks.
Like, he's already a little shaky. He's a little shaky already.
>> On that note,
Unk Chunk Wigert aka Shaky Ga.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait. Hassan read Chank's tweets.
What
is it? Shank tweet? Hold on.
does no good. >> That's not it. I don't see any changes.
>> Well, you have the opportunity. You have the stage.
Charles, >> I'll go. I'll see if I can find it. >> Give
me a second.
>> Apparently, we've got Hassan reading
>> He's in hangs in balance. >> Pregaming the chanks
giving. Okay. >> But I don't
literally said I was a communist
>> when talking about me on his Twitter. So, I don't know
where he stands on a lot of issues. >> That's not true.
Hassan knows exactly where his uncle stands. He just doesn't
want to own any of those positions.
>> No Box Society. Thank you for the five gifted subs.
Let's go. W. Huge W. >> Where is it? Um,
let me see. This is how he promoted it on his own Twitter.
He said, "Watching Packers versus Lions with my son as our fantasy
football season hangs in balance. My daughter baking cookies.
Mom making the juiciest turkey in America. Who doesn't love this
country? #appy Thanksgiving # America
going to my communist nephew's house with [laughter]
Jake's already kneeling and he's just on Twitter. He hasn't even
he hasn't even entered Hassan's house. He's already kneeling
on this for Jake's giving
now also part of America almost even Americana now. God bless
freedom of speech. Love living in a free country where we're
allowed to think and argue whatever we want. That's so true.
Thanksgiving is like actually the only thing I look forward to
American Thanksgiving for. It's for Thanksgiving.
I love Thanksgiving. Okay.
God, never suggest deporting these two again. Okay. No matter
how bad Hassan gets, all right, I needs giving. It's the one
thing that keeps me like above water. When I'm drowning in the
world, I know Chankgs giving will be there. Okay. >> He
is literally becoming the the crazy. This is the most This is
the most crazy uncle post of all time. My communist nephew's
house. >> I will not stop saying chanksgiving. It is Thanksgiving
today. >> I don't think he enjoyed your China >> What?
What are you thankful for? What are you thankful for? Ex Normie,
can we go around the room? Everybody just says what their name
is. You got to introduce yourself. We have some new people here.
Could you say your name and say what you are thankful for? Okay.
>> As much as you did. No. went to China and then straight
off the bat live streaming shouting at an ug. Yeah.
>> Think he's Wait, are you not a I mean you're some you're
something close to a communist. You you got that Mal Red book
and like we're totally down for it. What? Just like dox ourselves
wanksgiving
or I mean say your username. I don't know. >> Here the
the Jensengs giving conversations evolve
and and resemble the normal American Thanksgiving conversations.
Thanksgiving. I'm going to # jinxgiving. Only crime in LA homelessness
will come up. >> I didn't see this. Oh boy. >> 2022
Jinx was prophetic. And you watch after October 7th. The one
with the honkers is better. Yeah, I didn't post that one. I thought
it was maybe too much. This No,
>> the more affordable will expire. >> All right.
>> Are you guys on the affordable care? >> He read
the He read the tweets. We got the tweets in now.
Let's get it. Let's get it.
brothers. >> You can speak into it, but on that note, >> got
to watch him roll in again. Okay. >> Wigger aka Shaky Ga.
Got a chair. >> Hold on. You are you all right? You sound
sick. >> No, no, I'm good. >> Hold on. I'll I'll
grab you a chair right now. Here. The mic is The mic is on. You
can speak into it, but I'll >> Hey, what's up, guys? >> Oh,
don't show your phone.
>> What's up? Happy Thanksgiving,
>> My mom makes some good turkey.
>> He's just fully leaning into it now, too. Amazing.
>> Yeah, right there, brothers and sisters. Right there.
>> Uh at Jay Talk, I think if you dedicated a few minutes
every day to fighting against capitalism and fighting for the
workers, the stream would be better. No, no, thank you. Uh I
I aspire to be a capitalist overlord someday. I want to be the
person who controls the capital, who is rich, who has the yacht.
Okay, that's me. >> Yeah. Yeah, I got one. There you go.
You all right?
>> People are People are spamming.
>> They should. [laughter] I like it. Shaky G is in the
building, everybody. Hold on.
All right. This is Yeah, this is good. This is a better angle,
I think. And you can even Hold on. Let me fix this. Let me zoom
in a little bit more.
Boom. Yeah. Better. Less stomach.
>> Okay, there it is. Can you guys hear him? As you guys
know, it's a it's a timehonored tradition every single year uh
since 2018 to have
uh Jenk Uger in the building. Uh okay, let's start off with
why you said that you were going to your communist nephew's house.
>> I can't tell if you were meing or if you're being serious.
Have I been upgraded to communist?
>> Okay, actually, you tell me. I'm I'm kidding. Okay.
Okay. He's He's kidding, but he means something. He I Hassan,
I'm kidding. But also, Hassan, I'm kidding. But really, Hassan,
I'm kidding, but like, can you tell me just real quick? >> But,
uh, so people are constantly calling you all sorts of names.
You go to China. You love it over there. So, what should we call
you? What are you? >> I mean, I I say I'm a I'm a socialist.
I don't I'm not like a self-described communist or anything,
but I also say that I don't have an issue with people calling
me a communist. I just think it's funny when people say that.
>> Okay. All right. Then I got it right. Okay. I was playing
around. Yeah, you're a socialist. God bless. >> Yeah. Um
>> I hate this setup. They aren't even looking at each
other. We don't [__] with the formula, Zage. Okay.
The formula has been this since since the stream started. We
don't with the
>> But uh yeah. No, a lot of people are saying that I'm
a authoritarian
>> That's what they're saying. Well, not everybody. Some
people say I'm a revisionist and therefore a social
>> but those guys authority.
>> Cyberdrifter with the 10 gifted. Let's go. Thank you
very much, Cyberdrifter. Appreciate it. Appreciate you. Thank
you. Thank you. Thank you.
That's uh more time on the stream. I'll do the calculation in
a little bit. Let's get through some content first. But thank
you so much for the 10 gifted big 10 gifties. Thank you. Thank
you. >> You know what I mean? Those those are those are
that's the real max left. >> Okay. Yeah. Luckily, I don't
even know those folks.
>> You probably they're they're in your replies, I suspect.
Actually, they might have given up on you at this point. >> Oh,
yeah. >> They yell at me all the time, though. Not that
it matters. All right. Um I will keep calling you a centrist,
L. Yeah, people say I'm a I'm a centrist.
>> Well, the political spectrum has moved if you are a
centrist. >> So, um
although kind of I mean, look, you backed Mom Donnie 200%.
Mom Donnie is now uh bros with Trump. I mean, if that's not >> the
horseshoe is the horseshoe. Yeah. And by transited property,
I'm homies with Trump. But obviously, we already knew that. And
and technically you, too, because we were far too critical of
Kla Harris. And if you're critical of Kla Harris, who was the
best possible candidate at the time, uh that means you wanted
Donald Trump to win.
>> Yeah. I actually think that we have thoroughly defeated
those guys. So there's a lot of folks out there that [laughter]
are still in the, you know, in the >> Cheng tells Hassan,
"Hassan, don't worry about Hutch, okay? We already knelt on this
guy, okay? We already cracked that egg. Don't worry about that
guy. We're good here." >> Circle for uh for who might come
out ahead, right, in terms of ideology. But the guys who are
not going to win, I don't think, are the ones who are like, "Oh,
Kamla was right all along." Like that's kind of done, right?
So the way that that makes a comeback is through the form of
Buddhaj or Newsome, right? So those guys aren't done, >> but
like the commla stands, the beehive is dead, right? There's not
a single >> Khive. Yeah. >> Yeah. Khive, right? Right.
Right. There's not a left in the hive. >> Yeah. Beehive
is is very much alive. There's a beehive. >> Behive. Yeah,
that's that's [clears throat] the biggest one. Uh but uh yeah,
but her and Taylor Swift >> I can't. These people are such
grifting scum. Really?
Wait, where's the grift at this point?
Dude, you have a horrible horrible engagement with with internet
politics.
These two are just like exchanging pleasantries before talking
about some politics stuff and and you're like, "Ah, these people
are such grifting scum." They're just like, "Hey, what's up?
How's it going? You made this joke about me. What does that mean?
>> Be immortal. Uh but in politics
is done. >> All right. So,
um
we've had we've had many battles on this broadcast about our
disagreements,
but I think it's important to start the conversation with our
agreements. You've been uh manning the ship on Piers Morgan uh
every single time you appear. Uh >> Oh, we're going to
I The other thing I have for content today is some Piers Morgan
adjacent stuff. Okay. Piers had a talk with Tucker and then he
sent an invite to Fuentes and I think we're going to get that
conversation pretty soon as well. All right. I think this whole
thing comes up on here eventually. We'll check it out. >> Uh
Palestinians and Palestinian humanity. Has your attitude shifted
on this issue over the last two years? >> Maybe a little
bit actually. That's interesting. So, I've always been uh obviously
against uh all of Israel's war crimes, its occupation,
uh etc. And so, October 7th uh the day itself
was of course bad and then the reaction has been horrific and
it's an obvious genocide. And we said that from day one. We took
a lot of [__] for saying it's a genocide early. We
took a lot of [__] for saying they were doing it
to steal land. Uh oh, trope blah blah blah, right? And they stole
the land. It was always for ethnic cleansing. So, we've been
on the right side of that through and through. The only thing
that I'd say is that
um
I didn't,
you know, I grew up in East Brunswick, which is a kind of a
>> communist safe haven. I it's it's a it's the original
Israel. It's a safe haven for Jews. So it was about 40 50, right?
So I grew up uh with a culture that believed that Israel was
righteous and holy, right? And so I think that through this 2-year
process, I've now come to the point where like no, it's no question
at all that it shouldn't have been formed. And uh
>> And uh and so that's a kind of a I wasn't there before.
>> Oh, no. I know. >> Yeah. And and of huge injustice
and I've always known it was a huge injustice. In fact, this
the one thing I used to catch [__] for. I you know,
because I was
>> back in high school and we went to model Congress and
I was the only one who got a bill passed and it was to defund
Israel. That was back in 1988.
Okay. So, I've been I knew that it was a >> Wow. Sounds
like this guy has been this guy's been anti-Semitic for a long
time, >> I knew the occupation was terrible all >> How
did Chank do it? How did he be anti-Semitic for this long? Really,
>> Like, now seeing the totality of the circumstances,
as much as after the Holocaust, I get the overwhelming need for
a safe haven for the world. It turns >> yeah, East Brunswick,
New Jersey. >> Exactly. East Brunswick was totally fine.
Uh, and and no, it was the the original Zionist uh
>> No question. Israel Israel should not have been formed.
What? Wait, that's like literally my foundational thing is I
think basically there's an original grievance for the Palestinians
that Israel was formed under like false pretenses. They originally
started migrating there under false pretenses always with the
always with the intention of creating a nation there and they
they you know took the goodwill of the people there who did accept
them which were a lot of the people originally the first aliyah
and used it against them and then eventually just formed their
state there. Yeah, I absolutely don't think Israel should have
ever been formed. I think that actually the Palestinians had
a right to to be upset about that. And then after that, Slime,
you probably just don't comment on this stuff. Okay. Actually,
you got to go again. You're another week
I've I've actually like this is probably the last time you get
a week instead of just a perma. So, if you want to keep engaging
here, um you got to chill. Okay. Thank god I don't have the chat
on the screen. If I had the chat on the screen, I'd be getting
banned. Okay. So, you can't do that.
All right. Oh, yeah. So I I do think that the original grievance
of the Palestinians totally legitimate. I don't think I think
the tactics they used after losing the first war with the whole
Arab League horrible. I think that Israel was actually the you
know
at least I I don't think Israel did a lot wrong in the following
years on once they established their state. They didn't really
do a lot wrong in defending it. And then you get to like the
mid to late 80s and I think oh they've they've given up on ever
trying to find peace here and they're now the bad guys again.
So
yeah, anyway, that's that's about it. >> Of taking a people
without a land to a land without a people is by definition a
horrific injustice because the land did have a people and they
were the only way they were going to move them is by killing
them and that's what they did. So 1948 honestly was land theft.
1967 was definitely land theft. And by the way, this is the propaganda
that unks like me. >> And 1967 I don't know if it was land
theft. Okay, [laughter]
I'm sorry. I don't know. I don't know if it was land theft in
>> up with we were taught that 1967
defensive war. >> Yeah. No, no, not even. We were taught
that Israel was attacked just flat out >> the greatest
military conquest of all. Right. That's that's the way it's
>> Wait, who taught you that? Are we talking about the
the six- day war? >> So, it was taught to us that uh that
Israel was attacked and the they had no choice but to take to
destroy the air force of all of the neighboring countries to
destroy their militaries to defend. No, they Israel literally
just saw Okay, Israel literally just saw that all these countries
for some reason had their entire air forces sitting out like
they had their they had their bottoms down and they were looking
for anybody to them as in the ass as hard as possible. Egypt's
air force, Syria's air force, Jordan's air force. For some reason,
they decided that they were going to do this. I have no idea
why,
but I I imagine when you have a state like Israel and you're
like, "Oh, we can like do total military and economic devastation."
It wasn't some Yeah. No, it wasn't some military genius. It was
like the most incompetent
display
maybe in modern human history. Like maybe the most incompetent
set of circumstances that have ever come to pass. Yes. Yes. Egypt's
entire air force was sitting on the ground. Now, I think actually
at this point, interestingly enough, the concept of having hardened
bunkers for your flight for your um fighters and stuff for all
of your air force didn't really exist.
A lot of people at this point didn't really realize, oh, it's
a huge risk if if people can manage to fly under radar and get
to our airspace before we find out, all of our our entire air
force could be gone. We lose air air superiority like instantly.
We should build bunkers and stuff for our air for our airplanes.
Yeah, that just didn't really happen until that point.
>> And themselves preemptively. >> No, but that's
what I'm telling you. They didn't even add preemptively. They
just lied to us and said that the Arabs went first. Okay. Which
is just a flatout lie. And then and then so they said as and
I believed that at the time I'm a kid, right? But they had to
take buffer zones and that's why they originally took the West
Bank, Golan Height, Sinai, and Gaza. Uh but no, now I realize
no, the greater Israel project was from >> the Just real
quick, I don't want to ask, but what should happen to Israel?
um the same thing that should happen to the United States. It's
not like the United States took the land from the people there
under like good pretenses and it was like a good faith like you
know engagement where these two sides came to an understanding
right
like unfortunately there can be circumstances through which a
nation is founded that are really bad but once the people are
there you you don't just get to kill them all like Israel is
a country they're not they're never going anywhere you have to
move forward with them being a country >> uh they attacked
and they attacked last night in 67 to take more land and and
do more ethnic cleansing and that's what they I think given the
state of affairs in 2025, especially after two years of Israel's
genocide and also the endless amount of arrogance of Zionists
on television and their demands for censorship, this conversation
that's taking place is probably taking place in many American
tables regardless of the political uh ideology at play. You know,
you and I have differ in opinion on certain issues, but ultimately
this is something that we completely unite on and completely
agree on. And I think that is actually a point of agreement for
many people, even like evangelical Christians and whatnot that
uh are probably having the exact same conversation. So remember
that for the Thanksgiving and joy. Ooh, I have this a little
too fast. I need a little faster >> with your with your
family. If you want to unite on certain things, I think Israel
will probably be one of those points of contention. Uh or Zoramani.
>> What do you think about Zoramani?
>> Yeah, just real quick before we go to Zoran. Look, I
never thought this would happen in my lifetime. >> Oh yeah,
me either. >> Like that that Israel would be, you know,
that people would understand what's happening about Israel and
the injustice of Israel. uh not just on the left, but the left,
right, and center that the whole country would agree outside
of mainstream media, outside of the politicians. [laughter] No,
we're done with these guys. And the >> yo yo yo, Chank,
talk about the agreeers on the right wing. Talk about the agreeers,
Ch. >> This is a gigantic injustice. And most importantly,
we all now agree. We've all been lied to by legacy media, right?
Corporate media is poison. It's it's the biggest toxic influence
in America. Now, the right, the left, the center, everyone agrees.
Corporate media. They've been lying to us from day one. So, look,
that's another one. For 20 years, I've been saying that. And
to see everybody come around to that. I love it. I love it. So,
Zoron, so Zoron's to the left of me, so it makes sense that like
he's kind of perfect for you, right? I think you tell me. Um,
but but I love it. I love it because it's change. I love it because
middle finger to Apac that spent $45 million trying to meddle
in our elections and them. Why don't they go back to their own
country? Okay. New York is
>> Yeah. I mean, oh, you are just doing like really really
embarrassing Israel apology. I'm probably going to stop engaging
with you now. I mean, they're already there in the Bible, so
they have some claim. Yeah, they got genocided out. Okay. Roman
Empire came in and and the tried to rise up. Okay. They went,
"No, this Jesus guy, no him. He's not the Messiah. This other
guy, this other guy is the Messiah." And they rose up behind
that Messiah and overthrew their Roman overlords and then got
absolutely genocided off the face of the earth essentially, almost.
Okay.
No, they got ethnically cleansed out. Yeah, they they And by
the way, they came back after there were already like established
uh like established borders and stuff. They they came back way
later. So yeah, I the idea that you have a claim to somewhere
cuz you had it like 2,000 years ago is totally insane. Totally
pointless. Anybody who makes that point is not a good faith actor.
They're just a total. So I'm probably not going to engage with
your arguments anymore. I'm just going to watch Thanksg Thanksgiving
and enjoy myself. is in America. It's not in Israel. It's not
Tel Aviv. Okay? And and I'm proud that it's the largest uh city
and I'm proud that they voted for Zoron. Right? So this division
on uh trying to divide Americans, Muslim, Christian, etc. No,
we're America. They're not America. And that's that. And and
then he's for a change, man. The status quo. So I
Okay. Don't don't engage back. Um actually, they were there in
the Bible. So that means they get to come in while there's already
a population there and just form a country cuz they were there
in the Bible thousands of years ago. >> I'm thrilled that
Andrew Cuomo lost. >> What are the what why do you say
he's more to the left than you? >> So some of those policies
are not the direction I'd go, but I want him to try it anyway.
>> Like what what are the policies? >> So like rent
freeze on the rent control apartments. First of all, I don't
think he's saying that'll solve the whole thing. It won't. It
only affects a tiny amount of apartments, right? >> But
uh >> 1.2 million units or something, I think. >> Yeah.
which is not tiny actually, but >> I mean it's tiny for
New York, but go >> Yeah. Um but rent control in my opinion
doesn't work. It pushes up prices in other um apartment buildings.
In fact, I think it's counterproductive. I wish it worked. It's
a simpler solution. >> Okay, I don't think he is. >> Yeah.
Yeah. I'm >> Are you an abundant
cannot Okay. Hassan would be totally moronic if he wants to say,
"Oh, you think they should build more housing? You think rent
control like increases prices elsewhere? You think supply and
demand works? Are you an abundist? Are you an abund
like no,
you don't have to totally discount and throw away all of economics
because you want socialist or social like sock policies or if
you just want to build more housing to increase supply. These
are just natural laws. It's how it works, man. Like don't but
don't throw that to the abundoccrats. Don't throw that to like
the abundance like agenda people. Obviously, you should want
to build houses. Obviously, you should want to get prices down.
Obviously, basic economics are just like laws of nature. Can
we not? Can you not, Hassan? Please don't do that. Please. >> You're
an understander and appreciator. >> No, I mean, I'd have
that conversation with Ezra, and I think he's probably at least
a third right. Uh, but he's not right at the in like the central
thesis, which is uh which I think is misguided, right? Uh, but
no, on rent control, I'm definitely a centrist. >> Okay.
What about what about public
>> Yeah. What about building robust socialized housing
as a as a way to boost the number of available units and as a
way to deflate the existing uh uh housing market and the prices?
>> So, we've done public housing >> I miss sorry
I was I was following that other guy. I missed whatever the comment
was about the third right >> terribly in the past. We've
done public housing in rare cases pretty good in America. So,
but this is your >> you can't The problem with public housing
in places like New York and big cities is that the public housing
housing is almost always built for people who have like no economic
power whatsoever who are in like dire straits and people who
are in economic dire straits don't have like routines. They don't
have lives. They don't appreciate the houses they get and it
all gets destroyed. It all gets rund down. The neighborhoods
are unlivable in right.
Yes, I am being racist right now to some extent or I'm not, but
I'm going to say I'm being racist so people don't like get angry
about it and engage as though like I'm saying something that's
not real. I'm saying something that's totally real. Okay, JTO
reading Thomas Soul. It's not just No, it's not being discriminatory.
The fact of the matter is, okay,
when you have that level of abject poverty, society like ceases
to function. Society totally breaks down. You can't have that
level of abject poverty and have things like continue to work
and function. Okay? They just don't. They straight up don't.
So, you have to reckon with that. You have to do something about
that. You have to care about that.
Classist. Hold on. This is just true. It's just true everywhere,
right? If if people don't have the means to own anything and
they they literally don't work. They literally are like in abject
poverty where societyy's like disintegrated more or less, it's
unfortunately that is
oh man that there's just not a lot you can do.
Um you're right, we should not build homes for the poor. You
should make it for people who are doing certain things, right?
Like realistically I think probably the way you do it is you
have public housing that's attached to working on public projects.
Okay.
Hey, guess what? You are now a construction worker. Okay. You
get to live in this house so long as you are working this job.
You get to live in this house. You get to work this job. You
sign up for like basically making America better when you don't
have any other economic opportunities. Okay. That's how it should
work. Yeah. I think I think you do a massive you do a massive
public works like undertaking. You train people up. It's going
to be one of the most expensive, most economically like ambitious
projects in American history,
and you do that.
I think some places have tried mandatory work program requirements
to qualify for public housing. I don't know how well it worked.
Well, then I don't I don't know what to do. I think the solution
then is another one which is crazy. It's the same solution that
should take place for the Palestinians. Okay? And nobody likes
it cuz it's inhuman.
All right?
But it's not genocide. It's uh ethnic cleansing. All right? anywhere
where there's like a concentration of poverty, you actually take
those people and you move them into areas where there aren't
poors. You just you you actually you spread them out. Okay? Get
them to do public jobs in those areas. All right? It's not eugenics.
It's not but there there's something that happens when you have
a density of like poverty that people can't recover in those
areas. They'll never recover. It will always become like a total
festering hive of crime and and nothing. Uh, the way to address
this is to mix social housing or subsidized low-income housing
units. This way, the low-income units aren't all concentrated
in the poorest neighborhoods. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, there.
There you go, Porter Beller. Yeah, exactly. It's the concentration.
It's like the density. Okay. It's like if you could make a three-dimensional
like density graph and negative is like how far below the poverty
line you are. There's an actual divide by zero in some of the
like what you call like the projects in in urban America. Okay,
there's like an it's like you once you get there and you can
imagine people live at the bottom of that hole, they will never
climb out. There are so many factors working against you once
you have that level of uh like density in terms of poverty. You
just can't win. You literally can't win. It's over. There's a
word for that. I don't know what that is.
>> 2025 and Zoro's a smart guy. So, I hope we learned some
of our lessons that we don't like >> Well, he he can't
he hasn't ran on uh you know, building public housing. As a matter
of fact, I think it's a major area of weakness for the American
left in general because there's not a single Democrat that even
broaches the subject matter from that angle. And every single
person Oh, hello. We're just having a chat debate now. I'm not
even listening to Well, yeah, those poor neighborhoods need surrounding
capital. No, you need people around them who show them how to
function. Those neighborhoods are basically those neighborhoods.
You can just imagine this, Kila. Okay, we're all like running
a race. And those people by virtue of being born in those neighborhoods,
not because they're not because they're genetically inferior,
not because they're anything's like explicitly wrong with them
from birth or something, but through circumstance, they've essentially
had their legs cut off. And you're like, "Oh, you could just
we just need to like pay this guy a lot of money. We need to
make sure he doesn't have other factors in life going on, and
then he'll be able to run the race." It's like, no, they actually
have their legs cut off. You're you're trying to get them you
need to move them to other places. is we need to fit them with
prosthetics. It's like a way different thing. Okay.
And it's going to be like difficult, but you you spread it out
and you like fix it over time. I know. Hold on. I know plenty
of people that have lived in public housing and got their lives
together and made it out. You're acting like that doesn't ever
happen. No, lots of people will be exceptional and can have it
happen, but it's difficult. And and like the vast majority of
those people will never make it out.
They'll they'll live this perpetual like suffering, this endless
cycle of suffering over and over again. They'll have kids who
live this endless cycle of suffering. It needs to be stopped,
right? But unfortunately, it's going to take like really ambitious
stuff to get there. And it's not just going to take, oh, we throw
some money at it. Trust me, you cannot throw your money at it
and keep all of these people who have lived this way, who have
grown up in this way. You can't keep them all together. Blank.
The only way you can really get people to not act like Man, it's
starting to seem racist now. The way you get people to learn
how to function in society is by having them around functioning
society. But if you if you just take a bunch of people who can't
function in society and you throw money at the problem, they
don't learn to function in society, right? Unfortunately, these
people are like they need rehab. Maybe not have their legs cut
off. Their legs are like withered away. They need somebody who
can rehab them. People who like walk and show them how to walk
and and help them walk.
They're not like unreoverable. They're not like broken. I don't
want to look at people like that, okay? But it is
really, really, really rough.
It's a difficult problem to deal with. >> 2025 and Zoron's
a smart guy. So, I hope we learn some of our lessons that we
don't like. >> Well, he he can't he hasn't ran on uh you
know, building public housing. As a matter of fact, I think it's
a major area of weakness for the American left in general because
there's not a single Democrat that even broaches the subject
matter from that angle. and every single person um even though
it's the number one like affordability is the number one priority
but affordability as you know better than anybody else brackets
off into certain aspects right healthcare is a part of the affordability
conversation and I think Democrats do have or at least the left
flank in the Democratic party has a a really solid approach to
that socialized medicine for all but housing is another aspect
of this that no one ever talks about uh and or they do talk about
it but they don't actually have a sim a simple easy to understand
uh policy for it that's why We keep consistently going back and
forth on band-aid solutions, which you're right. Um, rent control
is a band-aid solution. Um, I'm in favor of of the decommodification
of house. >> Uh, rent control isn't just a band-aid solution.
Rent control is particularly because it is essentially buying
votes from people who are already like getting rent control.
It's like explicitly just a handout to certain people that kind
of over other people. It's it's actually a policy you probably
should never run on. people do it and I understand how some people
think it works and it's whatever and like
uh it's not it's not a great policy. Okay, it's just not. >> So
obviously this works uh in that direction, but >> I'm not
I'm not for decommodification of housing, but I agree with you
on public housing and I think that there's a right way to do
it. So the problem was that we concentrated poverty last time,
right, when we didn't know what we were doing in the 1960s and
70s. So now we've done it a right a couple of times. spread it
out a little bit and make it more mixed housing, but it at least
creates more units. Uh create helps supply and demand in bringing
down uh you know in creating higher supply, so bringing down
prices. So there's a lot of logic in it. >> Yeah. Um but
he's not he's not advocating for socialized housing, but I do
think that other people I do think that this is the next initiative.
>> I mean you socialize it's socialized housing is in you
want to incentivize builds. That is like the number one thing
every country needs to do right now. every western country is
they need to incentivize like build starts housing build starts
probably not even that that has always been the best approximation
but probably what they need to do is they need to start like
approving large scale projects in their city. You need some like
you need some fusion of the federal government and and um local
government that allows like eminent domain on buildings in
like urban centers. Okay. It's just like, "Oh, you've got like
four family like four single family housing units here. Yeah,
we're going to knock those down and build like a massive skyscraper.
Maybe like 12. Yeah, those those are going away. Sorry. Eminent
domain. Go [__] yourself. Get the [__]
out of here." Yeah. Until they only build luxury housing. Hold
on. You understand that in New York City it doesn't matter if
they knock down a bunch of buildings and just build massive luxury
only units, right?
that that still would relieve some of the pressures that would
still allow prices to to stagnate over time so that we could
inflate into them. Like it doesn't matter what kind of apartments
you buy. You just need more. It even all luxury ones, those will
all get bought. It's New York City.
Trust me, there's lots of rich people in New York City who live
in shoe boxes and for for a reasonable price would upgrade at
the drop of a hat. There's tons of them. If the Democrats actually
do have this robust left flank movement and you know start unseeding
uh establishment Democrats and put forward like you know DSA
candidates and things of that nature um I hope that there will
be a more united message on that where people will people will
approach the subject of housing in a similar vein. Um yeah where
where they do talk about like u where they do talk about you
know permanent public housing and and better
>> Yeah. So the other thing that I I don't necessarily
agree with but I want them to try is the uh the cityrun grocery
stores. Um, so like I don't get it. I don't know why. >> Oh,
why don't you get it, dude? Chank Chen has to look at some of
the data from around the world where these things get mixed in.
Okay. In Canada, there's there's some provinces that have uh
what is it? They have public telecom. They have public uh insurance
like car insurance. And look at how it controls prices for everybody
and the satisfaction with those things.
The offset is crazy.
And not only the offset is already crazy, but it's not just the
offset in terms of oh, like the prices are lower here for everybody.
It's not just that offset. It also keeps some of the people,
some of the companies that operate in other provinces from going
totally buck wild on increasing prices and being because they
know that with good examples right beside them, there's only
so far they can go in terms of gouging people, or else everybody
in their province will just come along and go, "Actually, we
need to publicize this. We need a public utility.
These people are gouging people for the internet and for like
mobile data. It's >> And that's the biggest among the biggest
priorities. I get some food deserts. I get that there's some,
you know, some more high density minority areas where it could
be helpful. On the other hand, it's like a Muslim un unemployment
plan in in New York. All the bodeas are run by Muslims. Uh so
I'm I'm exaggerating, but but uh like I don't know that that
was a big pressing need, but I want him to try it. I want him
to try the free bus, and if it works, great. If it doesn't work,
so what? So why do capitalists uh hate government intervention
in the markets? Because they want to set the prices uh under
what they consider as market conditions. So basically I think
the way this would work, it's a pilot program um with no assurances
that it'll be 100% successful. But I think ultimately the goal
there is to try and and uh drive down profits with a a much which
with much better much more affordable groceries being sold because
there's a bunch of different things that that you don't have
to pay for like licensing and things of that nature when you
have the governmentr run grocery stores. So therefore the goal
is to to drive down prices for other grocery chains specifically
like the big >> Wow, this wouldn't uh this wouldn't pause
as I walked away. Now, the one thing I will say is that I think
there is something that is the most efficient price control.
And I recently spent some time around New York City. I didn't
realize how good like Amazon Prime groceries are. Like how insanely
good they are. I think for better or worse, Amazon is like one
of the most effective price controls because they can make money
at such a tiny margin that they Yeah, they make money at such
a tiny margin. they can just actually follow market pricing.
They're always going to beat most stores. They're almost always
going to beat most stores because they sell at such a scale that
it doesn't
So, I don't know. I was really up on the government run stores
in New York City until I realized how good like Amazon Fresh
is like Yeah. the Amazon Fresh deliveries and holy, it's amazing.
>> Big uh retailers, I think, like big grocery chains in
general. >> Yeah, let's try it. See what happens. >> Yeah.
Also, they do have it. I mean, it's the commissary in the military,
right? Which the Trump administration is trying to privatize
right now cuz I think they just want to do a mutiny. They want
to they want >> uh is it in NYC? Is it Whole Foods based
or something else? You get some items from Whole Foods and Whole
Foods is one of the vendors that you can buy from. You can explicitly
go to the Whole Foods part of Amazon Fresh and they will deliver
from home foods for you with like the same infrastructure, but
then you or not Home Foods, Whole Foods, but then you pay Whole
Foods pricing. Jank is sweating, bro. Chank's having a He's already
It's already rough, man. I don't even know why. It's still friendly
conversation. But no, I didn't. Oh, yeah. No, I streamed a little
bit from New York
and I didn't tell you. Yes. But now I'm home, so now I can tell
you I was in New York. >> Want to fment mutiny in the in
the
>> So, look, if you're on the right and you're like, "Oh,
you just want to just try it?" Like, yeah, because that's the
how we learn, right? But that's how they that's how so many people
voted for Donald Trump. Oh, I just want to try it out again cuz
we got to shake up the >> Yeah. And we're the states are
supposed to be, you know, uh, laboratories where we experiment.
And by the way, some of the rights say, "Oh, well, oh, can you
name it?" I some guy on Fox was like, "Can you name any time
that they made something public and it worked better?"
>> uh, I got free deliveries here, BB Poison, when I was
there. I got I just signed up for the trial. I got free deliveries.
the whole time. Or maybe it was that I had to pay. No, I think
I got free deliveries with Prime. You just had to pay like 25
bucks or more or something. It was 25 bucks or more. It was free
delivery. >> Uh yeah, like a bank in North Dakota. Uh they
created a state bank. It worked >> Uh uh uh municipal utilities.
>> Yeah. Literally almost every time every single time
the the municipality has taken over utilities, it has been so
successful that Google worked extra hard to make it illegal in
other places. Like they do not want internet service providers
uh or water or electricity or sewage systems to be uh to be controlled
by the municipality.
Um, but yes, >> that by the way, that's like the one thing
that works in I swear to God, I can't even fathom you guys having
private utility companies.
I It doesn't make any sense to me. Especially like I feel like
my take on like modern day capitalism is that it's it's now we've
reached economies of scale to the point where like they can optimize
out anything that brings joy in the world. Like anything that
brings joy in the world, they will meticulously work out of the
system. Like something that brought joy in the world was like
when you went to Chipotle and they just give you like extra ingredients
for like nothing. They they didn't have like Now every single
restaurant, every single restaurant you go to has measuring cups
for everything. They don't overfill a single thing. There's never
once been like extra anything on any order of anything for years
now, right? It's like that's that's like what capitalism does
at some point. it starts optimizing out like I think I think
pieces that are like joyful
and you don't get that when you have a governmentr run utility
now are there joyful things with no it's just that that it's
cheap but then also if stuff gets like knocked down the government
has like a responsibility to put it back up like if your internet
gets knocked down and you're just in a neighborhood where they
don't make that much money a private utility doesn't really have
to go put it back up but utility but like a public utility would
right because they're serving the public
there's like there's another there's like a thing going on there
that is worth protecting and is quite good. Yeah, exactly. Like
I've never Dude, I can't fathom having like private utilities.
It's crazy.
I don't know. It's nuts. And I've never seen an example of somewhere
that does private utilities that has better service than public
utilities where I >> Fire department is another great example
of this as well. And that goes to the last point which is we
don't know what should be public and private perfectly until
we try a couple of different systems. Like theoretically you
know it a little bit better. If you study other countries you'll
have better examples etc. But like the fire department used to
be private and that turned into a disaster because if you're
>> I got an idea of what should be public and what should
be private. >> You know I I think most of it should be
publicly owned. >> Yeah. And I think most of it should
be privately owned. >> That's crazy. >> But that's
okay. >> You're living in it. You This is >> No,
it isn't. It isn't. So, okay. Now, I'll make an argument that
I'm a better capitalist than anyone on the right way. >> Okay.
Let's hear it. >> Because the capitalism is all about free
markets and competition. The problem is that right now >> Chank
is unfortunately CH is going to hypothesize something um some
decentralized like
micro service microility
thing where you have different utility providers everywhere.
It'll be like the South Korea telecom hypothetical. Okay, in
South Korea the telecoms are all like there are big ones. It's
like a huge thing there. There's huge backbone network investment.
The internet in South Korea is always insane, right? That'll
be like the example. But most utilities aren't really that profitable.
They'll never be that profitable in South Korea. I actually don't
even know why it's all that profitable or why those those companies
make so much money. But it it'll never be like that in most places
for most utilities. I hope he doesn't go with South Korea hypothetical.
Okay. Oh, density, right? Uh you're No, you're right. You're
right. You're right. You're right. Um population density obviously.
I didn't think about it. So
yeah, it just for America that doesn't work, right? This is the
whole argument. For America that doesn't work. America's backbone's
all spread out. Providing utilities is significantly less uh
profitable. Yeah. It's like, oh, if you're providing utilities
just for New York City, maybe private stuff would work in New
York City. Maybe you could have private investment in New York
City and it would work really well. But in areas that aren't
dense, it's just public utilities are always going to be better.
Always, always, always. how what the uni part is in favor of
what almost all the Republican politicians are in favor of and
what a lot of the right-wing got tricked for a long time into
being in favor of is corporatism right so this is unregulated
capitalism which then leads to corporate rule capture corporations
capture the >> it's it's the natural inclination of every
company to become a monopoly and it's that's just and that's
I'm actually >> yeah and but also like the level of
Unfortunately, you also live in an era where totally untraceable
communication between parties can exist.
And what do you do when that exists? Like what are you supposed
to how do you stop people from doing it now? Like how do you
stop big companies from from just coming up with a scheme that
is fairly untra untraceable, unprovable where they price coordinate
or uh what is it? Price fix. I don't know. I feel like it's actually
getting more and more difficult to stop that kind of thing from
happening. Like companies have to be really really dumb to get
caught doing this now at this point
>> with you. So what happens >> spies? I'm saying
you only do this at the highest level. You let nobody into the
circle who isn't like massively incentivized to keep it private.
>> If you don't regulate capitalism, it inevitably becomes
corporatism. And corporatism is the exact opposite of capitalism.
It tries to destroy free markets, destroy competition, and become
a monopoly. Right? And it does it mainly through government capture.
So Adam Smith was right. You have to guard against monopolies.
You must regulate. If you don't regulate, then capitalism will
turn into corporatism and destroy free markets. So that's why
that position is more ideologically. >> But you're not
in favor of that for
>> No, that because capitalism
means by definition a mixed economy, right? There is no non-mixed
economies. Military's public, police are public, fire's public.
And so when you go down the list, health care is perfect for
public. Health care insurance
is perfect for public rather than private. Why? Number one, like
>> I feel like most of the arguments around this will serve
in the exact same capacity for
utilities. It it all comes down to sharing risk and like sharing
downside. And society is just happier when you share this downside
for certain things. >> Like fires, viruses spread. So whether
your neighbor is healthy or not is relevant to you. Number two,
it's a combined pool makes it a lot uh less uh you know more
efficient. And then most importantly, if you put a profit motive
on denying health care, which is your cost, they will deny health
care to the maximum to their maximum ability to maximize profit.
So then you've literally built an industry that is better served
by more people, right? So, and that's why over 70,000 Americans
die every year because they don't have health insurance. That's
among the reasons why. And way more die. Wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. Can you blame the health? Maybe you can.
Okay, okay, okay.
Maybe, maybe you can. I was like, wait. You're going to blame
them when they don't cover people? I get it when, bro. It's like
way more upsetting to me when I hear about people who have healthcare
and then the one time they go to use their healthcare, they get
denied.
That I
that isn't the Luigi case, but like I think that's why everybody
sort of understood in their soul why the Luigi thing happened,
right? Like a lot like I wouldn't say it's okay or good, but
damn, everybody got it. It's like, dude, there's so many stories
that you hear from Americans of like, yeah, uh I paid my premiums
for years and years and then they just denied my claim for like
my my heart surgery or something.
Get the out of here. >> Because they didn't their insurance
didn't cover the thing that they had because we privatized it.
It's actually mental to privatize health insurance. It's just
as dumb as privatizing cops or even worse, the fire department.
>> I mean, I feel the same way about housing in general.
Like, I I don't think it means that it has to be like gray brutalist
architecture and city blocks. There are plenty of examples from
Singapore to China all the way to
>> I don't know how you mix the the private and public
part of healthcare without
without getting like the college issue without getting the issue
you have now where like the prices all get max like massively
increased on everything
like I don't know how you get rid of the current system like
the current costs in America that are objectively just way higher
than anywhere else on the planet like insanely high. How do you
get rid of that? I don't know how you work that out of the system.
>> Austria, Vienna, weird, where socialized housing uh
runs supreme. Even in Hong Kong, as a matter of fact, and I was
actually surprised to find this out, but I believe it's like
52%
of everyone living in Hong Kong actually live in uh government
housing. But that also has a major uh benefits cliff. So that
actually keeps uh uh wages relatively low or people unemployed
in an effort to make sure that they're still in government housing
because every every uh house that is not owned by the government
uh that is not public housing uh is so unimaginably expensive
like the price difference is like 300 let's say the price difference
is like $300 for government. Does wait.
Why does this sound like rent control if he's talking about this
right now? I'm confused. How did he just support rent control
and then he grabs Dude, this is Chank like he this just argued
against me on rent control and now he's arguing with my exact
point for why rent control is bad. [__] is going
on here? Is happening here? Housing versus like $7,000 for a
private unit. like the the cheapest private unit is so much higher
that people would rather just like be unemployed than to actually
get like that that fiscal cliff would not exist under a universal
program. And uh if people wanted luxury housing beyond that,
uh you know, they could they could choose to spend all the extra
dollars and get taxed out the ass in order to have the uh luxurious
privilege of having uh this this mega mansion or
>> Yeah. So, look, I I'm not anywhere near that. I I think
housing should be totally private, but not totally private. I'm
willing to experiment with public housing uh in certain circumstances
and see how it goes and how does it affect the market? Does it,
you know, like we talked about earlier, create more supply and
and hence help with prices, right? And you know, is there a bare
minimum where we should help people not be on the streets? Of
course, right? So then you know in the lower levels you're having
a conversation is what degree is it public because if they're
in the I think we all agree if they're homeless and they want
shelter we should give them shelter right so that's in a sense
public housing like the lowest lowest >> but it's not permanent
right so it's not permanent but I'm just saying that at the lower
levels by definition you have to have some sort of public housing
>> yeah you're saying like you you have to have some sort
of permanent public housing for people who just like literally
have no other option >> I I think that that's a possibility,
right? And >> dude, I'm I This is where I like start coming
up with weird I start coming up with like weird hypotheticals.
Like, do you need
How do you fix the homeless thing? Cuz being homeless in New
York, I could see a lot of people bordering on like just wanting
to be homeless in New York over living almost anywhere else.
Like that just being in New York City, being able to walk around
in New York City, you just get like a gym membership, you shower
there in the morning, you get ready, then you go do your your
day. That be like living in a homeless shelter in New York might
not even be that bad. So, what do you do with people? What do
you do with the homeless population? Do you offer them like shelter,
but we send you to an island in the Pacific? We send you to like
Hawaii, not Hawaii literally, but somewhere around Hawaii. I
have no idea. I'm like trying to think of like how I would want
to solve that or how you could solve it cuz if you just provide
a lot of like homeless shelter, a lot of homeless housing in
New York, I feel like you're just going to find a lot of people
will want to be homeless in New York. Why should New Yorkers
want that? So uh but in terms but the minute you get into the
middle class and beyond you got to have a normal market.
>> I think >> why why do you think so? Like what
do you think are the downsides of of public
>> Anytime that we like like I do believe in the markets.
So if you're going to have public sneakers or burgers or jeans
or even houses or cars, >> okay, there's a difference.
>> One is one is what is the what is the problem? Oh man,
this is where having like a really fractured national
like identity, a really fractured
and broken patriot, you know, a patriotic feeling in the United
States. People don't love the country. It's like, where's the
great American, dude? This is why you have to get Donald Trump's
ego going. Okay, where's the great American who will run the
housing projects and put their names on them, but they will run
them in a way that like they actually maybe not Trump cuz he
won't pay people, but run them with like Yes. It's like with
a public works program, get these people to work, get these people
to do stuff and pay them a little bit more. Yeah, you will pay
like a little bit more, but it will be comfortable jobs. These
people will get a wage, they'll get benefits, and then build
houses, but don't build like public housing. Don't build don't
build like um don't build like the projects. Build in like high
income areas. Go do government housing. that maybe that is the
way Donald Trump Trump led luxury housing in New York City. Donald
Trump himself, okay, we give him a third term. He goes to every
major city and he just puts up Trump buildings everywhere. Trump
luxury housing in every major city. We get a brand new Trump
building, okay? And it's the one way to get the government to
pay for all of this, right? the only the only president ever
with enough of an ego that he'd just let the government actually
engage in all these housing projects, all these luxury housing
projects everywhere. He knows how to build hotels. You know how
to build hotels. You can build housing, right? We give Trump
permits to build everywhere. They're not his buildings. They're
government buildings, right? They're public buildings. The revenues
from them are public and and they could be leased out to people.
All made out of pure solid gold. I don't know. There's like there's
got to be something there. But the issue with government housing
is it's always built for like the lowest class people, which
is like fine. But if you build for the upper class people, you
you just build all of the luxury for the upper class people.
Why not?
Why not, man? Tend not to buy into the notion that lobbying is
as powerful as people say it is for most things, but the force
of lobbying from real estate investors is uniquely enormous.
Really,
what do they lobby for? Cuz I I feel like the thing that slows
down housing builds is the nimism, right? I feel like that's
almost a universally agreed upon thing. Is there something else
there that most people don't see? Like I I do get that real estate
investors lobby to get like casinos built and [__]
because that's literally why Trump Trump was just honest. He
was like that's why I pay every politician. I need to get my
built. Okay, that's what I do. I build so I need to pay them
all. I need everybody on my side. If Trump wasn't No, you tap
into the egoomaniac part. I think Oh, they they're a municipal
lobby so they do go and tell people. Well, that's really easy,
though, because that's just that's just populism at the micro
level, right? Dude, did you hear that? They're going to build
apartments. They're like they're going to move in a bunch of
like low-inccome people to your neighborhood.
They're going to fix the problem of crime in New York City by
moving the criminals next to you. Dude, it's so I could Dude,
that is the easiest that's the easiest bill of goods to sell
somebody I've ever heard in my entire life. It's going to it's
going to overlook your property. They're going to bring a bunch
of criminals in. It's going to be gross, man. Do you really want
that? think of your property values
>> uh clothing
versus the other is is shelter though, right? Like I I that's
that's why I say like yeah, you can have you can have a
uh you can have a a a private market or a free enterprise for
small businesses for you know uh or even for uh certain goods
that people are offering. And uh but when it comes down to the
things that are necessary for survival, I I'm a believer that
um the the profit incentive uh creates a
uh creates a negative uh experience for people that that simply
need to get this thing to survive. And I think it would make
the >> man
that this is probably I'm just thinking like
it might just be the case that with how like here's the here's
the would you call it like the Gordian knot that's going on here
that like there's this unsolvable thing as your labor becomes
more and more devalued as you get less and less valuable to everybody
as a as a person as an economic unit there's no way to take that
power back through the free market. you most almost everybody
lacks that power. It was obvious when it was the manufacturers.
It's going to be obvious for like everybody else who's slowly
having their labor devalued, right? Hey, we could just send your
labor somewhere else. Hey, we could just do all this. The only
way to take that back might be like aggressive government control
of everything. Like, and not take it back, but to halt it. Like,
if you can't figure it out with the government, like you're either
way, don't let a bunch of rich people become like billionaires
off of you, off of like sending your labor elsewhere. you're
either way. You might as well try.
Like it might just be that that fascism or communism, one of
those two things is just going it has to go one of the two ways.
It really might be. It might just be that. Like I'm I'm starting
to see it. I understand that that didn't come about for a long
time. But it's like the unique thing that's changed isn't that
the free market doesn't work. The free market works perfectly
and a bunch of people are making gang busters profits. But it
is it is naturally now with the free market in a place where
where we've gone beyond human understanding to to try to get
into these markets to try to innovate in so many ways. Not totally,
but like that understanding there's so many places where you
could scrape out a really solid living as not that smart a person
in in almost every era, every year of human history. And I think
you're finding less and less is that the case now. It's not impossible.
You could still do it, but almost all of those places where where
dumb people are making money are things that are like borderline
griffs, like borderline scams, crypto streaming. Okay, Nvidia
is worth more than Germany. How the [__] is that
even possible? Uh, the prospect of all profits going through
Nvidia chips in the future, the prospect of all white collar
work going through these same chips,
that's how it's more valuable than Germany.
That's that's literally there. It is just automating out the
biggest cost you have which is your labor costs, right? You're
trying to automate out your labor costs. That's the goal of all
of these people. Yeah. No, this is this is broadly true. You
start to wonder, okay,
is the Dune thing just how it has to be? Do we need the
why wait for the singularity? Okay, when the tech jihad could
start today, [laughter] I don't mean that not literally don't
do anything crazy, but I don't know, man. I don't know. It will
be that or it will just be uh just so happen to be the case that
automation entrenches big business to the point that it's just
gated communities of marketable skill sets and tent cities. I'm
agnostic because I don't think regular people are as powerful
as they think even they are even in large groups. Well, you could
get like some kind of revolution now, but realistically like
weaponry, all of this is currently in the hands of the American
government is the number one producer, the number the the most
lethal thing that exists. But give it five years, 10 years. I
don't think that'll be the case. I think there is a decent shot
that private enterprise will start to catch up to the US military
in some way. I I do I think that is probably the case. I think
that's why Palmer Lucky started down that whole route. Now, currently
drones not happening, right? There aren't drones that can like
overtake the US military. Never happening. But
it will get to the point where where stuff will get discovered
and these private enterprises will
absolutely
there will be something like that. Okay. Where where they suddenly
have like the drop, man. It's one of those things where it's
like I don't want I don't want stuff to be that dire, but I actually
don't see it any other way at this point. Public overall much
more productive. And same goes for education. Uh same goes for
uh for housing and the same goes for like basic necessities such
as food. Um, even though there can obviously still be a private
market on top of that. So, >> but it seems like you're
saying all for like the bare necessity. >> Oh man, I'm
I'm getting so I'm getting so like conspiracy pill in my mind.
I mean, look at Palanteer becoming more embedded with the US
military infrastructure and in the intelligence community. Dude,
that is happening. And realistically, who trusts Peter Teal to
want or incentivize the current US hegemony? Like why the would
he not just use that position if he could or if Palanteer could
to undermine the US military? Why? Why? Like what what prevents
them from doing that, right? like undermining them. Like that
would be a big part of breaking things up in a way that you don't
have like a government in the way that like corporate interests
could just take over the planet is you need the the dominance
of the US military to be undermined. That's like problem number
one. You want to take over the world, you want to actually be
like a world dictator or a part of an oligarchic like world takeover.
What's the number one thing standing in your way? The the current
dominance of the US military is the number one thing.
If you were thinking of how to solve that problem,
very I don't know, man. O
Elon Musk controlling space is already Elon Musk doesn't control
space. The US uh it would cause catastrophic damage to all
human interest. Okay. But realistically, Elon ain't got no defense
up there. Okay. There's no defense up there for Elon's
Russia shoots down satellites. Okay. But the whole reason you
don't shoot down satellites is because eventually once you have
enough space junk up there, it starts to move at a velocity that's
fast enough that it will prevent any satellites from going up
in the future. It will destroy our existing satellite infrastructure.
Okay. Elon Musk vetoed an American op by turning off Starlink.
I thought he turn he vetoed an au uh Ukraine op, not an American
op. Effectively vetoed. I thought this was a Ukraine op where
they were going to hit Russia and he did that himself because
they were using his satellites. Now he has the ability to do
that and then he started sell Yeah. Kesler syndrome. Exactly.
Yeah. But that wasn't an American op and they were using Starlink
that they were using his like right now you could say he controls
like a worldwide internet service that can be used and I think
he immediately after that was like okay I'll for military operations
you can pay for this extra tier and then I won't be able to shut
it off. Although who cares like that's not fake. Oh sure sure.
So he controls the satellites. I'm just telling you he doesn't
control space and
Believe me, the US Elon's no billionaire, nobody around this
is actually like going to with the US government at this point.
That's that they're never going to pull put their dick on the
table and say, "I own you, US government." They're never going
to risk that. >> Which then makes more sense. Like at the
higher levels, you're going to let uh wealthy folks buy whatever
house they want, right? >> Yeah. I mean if if but but again
that needs to come with like uh that needs to come with a cost
so it's not as uh easily accessible like the reason why I went
back to Singapore as an example is because like it's there it's
tiny right and there's not a lot of cars and from what I understand
like in order to get a car in Singapore you have to be incredibly
wealthy and the reason for and the government has already uh
made it uh so easy to use public transit or to use uh bicycles
icles and and numerous different methods of transportation that
are not only cost effective but also much more uh viable for
uh climate change, right? Uh um ecological disaster, avoiding
ecological disaster. So the way the way that it should work,
I think is that if you want to get a if you want to get a car,
you have to get like penalized for it basically in that structure.
And the same goes for uh wanting luxury housing. Like I see housing
as a necessity uh and homes are for living in it rather than
uh rather than a speculative asset in the way that it works in
the United States of America. And we've sold to the Americans
that this concept is good and it actually invokes freedom just
as we have done with our car relant infrastructure. Oh, you have
your own car, you have uh so much freedom, you don't have to
sit with the with the rest >> Oh, Hassan's doing the the
really stupid thing. Okay, there is a very big difference. Okay,
you can't have and maybe this is the there probably needs to
be something like this. Okay,
for things like infrastructure, for things like um
Oh man, for for all the things Hassan's
those are programs that get put into place in places where there
is such population density, it's like insane not to have it,
right? Like New York City should probably have some more investment
in some of its public infrastructure. the subway the subway should
work a little bit better, but I think it's hard to actually do
in place fixes for the subway like in real time, right? Like
every time you you go to fix the subway in New York, you unfortunately
like put off everybody's commute immediately and the whole city
goes like has an uprising against you. All right, so I think
that's an issue there.
But
Singapore, you can't compare Singapore to the average American's
experience or like the a most Americans Oh, hold on. I actually
don't know what this is. Probably. I don't know how many Americans
live outside of the top five cities. Probably at least half of
them, right? Maybe more. Oh, no. Way more. Why did I say top
five cities? You have to do like top 100 cities. But I wonder
where you get to 50/50. Like how how many of the top X cities
until you get to like 50% of the population? Like America has
such a decentralized like hollowed out, not hollowed out, like
spread out population.
It's uh you can't have these solutions for most people. Like
you're literally not even talking. You include metro areas, maybe
it depends on how dense they are, but you you run into issues
of like, yeah, population density. Like America is so spread
out that it's very difficult to do these public utilities in
a way that makes sense. All these other cities built up in a
way that didn't have a ton of like uh a ton of single family
housing all over the middle of the cities to the public in a,
you know, subway or whatever, but that creates unimaginable traffic
density. It's worse for the uh climate overall and it even has
like it even has economic uh uh issues associated with it and
the same goes for housing too. >> Yeah. So look, I'm not
an expert on housing or >> sorry I wasn't talking about
housing. I was talking about transportation and >> car
regulations or anything but my general sense of it is no I I
first of all there's nothing wrong with disagreement but I I
don't I don't agree. So, so when you talk in bare necessities,
make sure people don't die in the streets, I totally agree. Right.
And I think that everyone agrees. I think that even the rightwing
agrees to that. I hope >> I don't think they do, but >> uh
yeah. Well, I mean, I think that if you said to them, shelter
for homeless people, they would generally say yes. Partly to
get them off the streets, but partly because, yeah, they think
they should have shelter, right? >> Oh, yeah. Congestion
pricing in New York City is like a a move in the right direction
of this sort as well. like making it more costly to to be able
to drive a vehicle actually increases
uh the the uh use for
uh for for public transit cuz then people are like all right
well I should I'd rather util
the other problem with this okay is just the what with what all
of Hassan's talking about the issue with being like a sock dem
in a world of populism okay is you're going to go and give your
message to the voters hey we're going to have to increase taxes
oh my taxes this. Yeah, you that's like that's the issue, right?
You're describing a bunch of pro like projects that cost money.
I don't think it's possible to get elected without just thoroughly
lying anymore. Like I don't think you you can't run an honest
campaign. Maybe that's always been the case, but >> public
transit then. >> Never mind. That's just always been the
case. I don't know why I'm pretending >> I I'm I'm mixed
on social engineering. Uh so I like I don't want to penalize
people for getting houses. I don't see the point of it. Uh and
I think that the wealth creation we did with uh for the middle
class in America with houses was amazing. It was one of the best
things we've ever done in American history. In fact, what I would
my uh part of my social engineering
>> um well first of all you can say any city planning is
social engineering. A [clears throat] bridge is social engineering.
Right. >> It it goes back to the same concept. Yes. All
matter of governance. >> Mani pulled it off. Yeah. But
I think Mumani stuff is not going to work in a lot of cases.
That the grocery stores can work. I think if they're trying to
make free buses, I don't know if that'll ever work. We'll see.
>> It's technically authoritarian. It's >> and just
like >> Oh, no. You could agree and once you agree, then
you executed, right? So, it's centralized
point of contact, right? >> Yeah. No, but but people are
still always going to disagree. Uh it's just that that it's for
the disagreeers that's technically authoritarian. for a that's
authoritarian that the government doesn't want him to kids. You
know what I mean? Like >> well I know but then
theory >> we're stretching the definition of authoritarian
because the authoritarian is one person controlling everyone.
>> well Barry Weiss thinks so and at le and he's more charismatic
than you apparent >> Yeah Barry [laughter] Weiss. >> Yeah
even though >> I found deeply >> dude that that Barry
Weiss clip was maybe the most thing dude.
Oh my god, that Barry Weiss clip. That was the dumbest I've ever
heard in my entire life. And CBS paid 150 million for it. CBS
paid 150 million for insights like that, for little nuggets of
of gold like that.
Crazy
>> even though um
uh yeah, Barry Weiss is trying to get me to debate Ben Shapiro,
who was sitting next to her when she said that. >> Um so
that was doubly funny for me. I was like, damn, you guys have
been trying to set up a debate between me and Ben Shapiro. Why
are you saying I need to be deplatformed? >> Yeah. And
uh apparently you're not inside the 40 yard lines. >> Anyways,
so look guys, uh you do government planning to set up a city
for sure. No question. Uh you need some degree of public everything,
right? Uh but then once you get into trying to, you know, get
into the pricing of things, that's where >> uh I don't
think Mumani is nuts. I think he's going to be sabotaged by a
lot of people working against him. I think unfortunately he he
lives and works at a scale where if it ever it'll become politically
like efficacious to to make him up everything to make everything
really for his run. He'll he'll just be an example right going
forward. Uh we'll see if he plays to Trump Trump's ego. Yeah,
it's possible if he plays to Trump's ego he might be okay. But
I think otherwise people will try to sabot sabotage him. I I
do think so. >> I'm out. I think the market should set
>> the one Oh, I keep interrupting these two. The one place
where Mandani has maybe a little grace is that I think
I think this all comes down to billionaires can like advocate
for things for other people really easily. Okay, really easily.
They can say this is how it should be. They can do that. But
in New York City, that's their city. And I don't think they'll
operate the same way necessarily. I think there's a good chance
that they don't operate the same way they usually do in New York
City specifically. Like in New York City, I think there's a chance
that they like let stuff go. They try to make stuff work because
they just want it to work in New York City, right? They want
it to work in their city. They want their city to be better.
But when it's everywhere else, it's like, "No, don't take my
taxes to put them somewhere else." But when it's in New York
City specifically, they're like, "Oh, well, yeah, let's try it.
Let's try to make this better." >> Some degree of public
everything, right? Uh but then once you get into trying to, you
know, get into the pricing of things, that's where I'm out. I
think the market should set the price. Uh for people that are
in middle class and above, for sure. Then the question is where's
the cut off? And that's a legitimate question to have. My solution
for part of my solution for housing is we have this populist
plank and uh like the rebellion pack candidates sign on to it.
And what that is is in that case is we ban private equity from
buying residential real estate. So uh and the reason we do that
is because when they buy the homes they're driving up prices
because they're limiting supply. They're increasing demand. By
definition prices are going to go up. and they have made pricing
go up tremendously,
right? And there's no reason why bankers should be allowed to
own private residential real estate and it destroys the wealth
creation for the middle class in America and they're going to
turn us all into renters and it's going to be a disaster.
let's uh I I there is a guy actually that has an opinion that
is now the next mayor of New York Zoramani on socialized housing.
Let's take a look. >> American housing is in crisis. You
might >> right now up to 12 million Americans are behind
an average of $5,800
on rent and risk eviction with eviction moratoriums. >> Bro,
how does get elected? How did that h What the
He's wearing a dress. He's wearing a dress right now. >> Soon
to expire. We're facing an unprecedented wave of evictions and
foreclosures that will crash straight into millions of struggling
families
>> Where did the that How did you let this guy win? Where?
What did What were you guys doing?
Did he Did he run on Shabbat? LIKE WHAT THE WHAT HAPPENED? How
did the let this happen the country? But the truth is this crisis
didn't begin with the pandemic. In fact, housing has been in
crisis for a very long time. Even before the pandemic in places
like New York or Los Angeles or San Francisco med it's drip.
You are coping so hard right now. Oh my god. You're coping so
incredibly [__] this
uh they should have run this ad. They should have run this in
ads all the time. This is goofy as
you can tell he's a way different. When he ran an election when
he ran a campaign,
you guys are you guys are just being contrarian for no reason.
When he ran the campaign, he obviously didn't wear the dress.
It's not drip. It's goofy as
>> The reason he wore a suit all the time. Actual drip.
Okay. rents for even one-bedroom apartments could approach $2500
a month or more. About a third of people in Los Angeles spend
a majority of their income on housing. In New York City, about
20% of all renters pay most of their income to their landlord.
And in my district, Atoria, about a quarter of residents have
to spend most of their paycheck on rent. And the crisis isn't
just in big cities. In 95% of all US counties, workers making
the minimum don't make enough to afford a one-bedroom rental
on their own. The Harvard Center for Housing Studies warns of
a new normal for housing in the United States in which nearly
half of all renter households spend almost a third of their income
on rent. That's why even before the fallout from the Corona virus
started to hit, more than half a million Americans nationwide
were already homeless. Millions more on the brink of losing their
housing and countless families struggling every month to make
ends meet. At the root of all of this suffer, >> dude,
this guy's got like the perfect voice for
like infotainment videos like this, doesn't he? I feel like he's
got the infotainment voice is the fact that in this country,
housing is treated as a commodity, not a right. It's a consumer
product just like clothes or cars that private businesses can
sell on the market to make a profit. And if someone isn't able
to pay, either because their landlord raised their rent or because
they can't work for one reason or another, they're not able to
stay in their homes. If they're lucky, they can live with friends
or family or maybe in transitional housing for a bit. But for
a lot of people, they have nowhere else to go and they end up
sleeping on the streets. In December 2019, the number of people
sleeping in homeless shelters in New York reached 19,000 people,
an all-time high. the number of uh homeless people uh that means
like couch surfers, people living in their cars and people living
in like you know tents and whatnot I believe is over 660,000
in the United States of Americaund
I feel when the nightmare scenario he's describing as the target
scenario for
h Canada Australia went so crazy um with like no possible reason
to
man it looks so bad in retrospect
like literally just hey um you you're having a housing crash
or you're having a housing market like explo cost you're having
a cost explosion in your housing market. Uh what if we throw
like you know importing 3% of the country every year like 3 4%
5% of the country if we just import them all into the urban areas
would that help? Would that help? Does that help? Did you guys
notice that helping? Hey, let's keep bringing in more and more
and more and more and more. Let's let's double the size of this
country in like five years. Let's go. Let's go.
No, don't do that. That's [__] That's boo That's
goofy as hell. 100,000 New York City students are homeless. Her
Jtock, you see that made your goods cheaper, bro? All of these
people All of these people just drive like Uber Eats and it's
crazy.
That's more than 10% of the entire student population.
Why do so many people end up homeless? It's not because there
aren't enough homes to go around. There are plenty of empty homes.
No, it's because housing people is not the primary goal of developers
or landlords. Their goal, simply put, is to make a profit. And
it's much more profitable to build luxury apartments for the
rich than decent homes for the poor. This gives us a big Dude,
how does nobody wait, did nobody under did nobody explain to
these people, at least for New York City, I don't know how you
get it to work in like other places, okay? But in New York City,
you just build massive luxury condos for everybody. Just keep
building luxury condos over and over and over again. People will
pay for them. People will buy them. And don't, by the way, don't
sell them. Lease them to people who live in New York City, who
work in New York City. Just only lease them. Don't allow sublets.
Just lease them directly.
Shortage of homes for ordinary working people. For every hundred
households that are extremely low income, there are only 36 affordable
and available homes. As a It's like this demonizing of luxury
apartments. Why? Why? Why do you keep demonizing it? JTO just
wants to push out the poor. Uh hello.
Are you Are you serious? No, you This is If that's where you
start, if you can get people to do that,
you start there. So, I'm talking about New York City specifically.
Everybody will live in New York City. Okay.
Um total housing supply does help, but without any mandate for
low-inccome units, the improvements are marginal.
Why would it be marginal? You only lease. You don't you don't
sell. You only lease. You only lease do you like five 10 year
leases or something? That's it. >> As a result, we have
plenty of housing for the rich, but poor. Why not just build
affordable units? Because no housing that comes onto the market
in New York City right now will be affordable to anybody who
wants who's a low-income resident. And working-class people don't
have nearly enough on the market. So, we have people scrging
to make ends meet or sleeping on the streets right below luxury
condos and uninhabited apartments. This is a terrible way to
organize a housing market. It might be profitable for landlords
and developers, but it's not efficient or beneficial for the
rest. >> The argument is the same. If there's inelastic
demand for healthcare,
which there is, right? What is an inelastic demand? If you don't
uh for those of you who don't know, inelastic demand is if a
good or a service is uh impossible to avoid, you need it for
survival. as in if you're a diabetic, you need insulin. So no
matter what the supplier
uh if the suppl
says more than half the apartments in NYC are empty right now
because of rent control. What that is maybe the most claim I've
ever heard in my entire life. That is like the dumbest thing
I've ever heard in my entire life. I don't know. Hi. Like you
just said something so cataclysmically
that the entire chat, the video stopped, everything stopped just
to look at you and be like, you want to explain what you could
possibly mean right now because nobody understands. Look it up,
bud. No, how about you look it up?
>> Supplier restricts the the number of of insulin shots
that are readily available and the price the price will automatically
go up because it's an absolute necessity. If you don't pay for
insulin, you're going to die.
I say so NYC vacancy rate IS 1.4%. NO, 50%. It's 50% vacancy
across the entire entire
city. It's 50 There's 50% vacancy because of rent control. That
doesn't affect even like more than 5% of units
or 10% of units.
Like the rent control section of apartments that exist in New
York City is small compared to the overall set of >> The
same argument goes for housing. Housing is
uh an inelastic demand good because if you don't have housing,
you
>> Yeah. Again, at the lower levels, uh once you get into
middle class, I this has not been that persuasive to me. >> Well,
hold on. There's more to the video. There's five more minutes.
Let's take a look. This guy seems like real real charismatic.
Got a real >> Does he mean half of the empty ones are empty
because of rent control? I mean, that doesn't make any sense.
So maybe you would say empty because of rent control because
if they lease it out right away or something, it has to stay
rent controlled and if it's vacant for a certain period of time,
they can un rent control it or something. There's like some loophole
that's happening there. To say it's because of rent control,
like foundationally doesn't make any sense because obviously
if the apartment is cheap because of rent control, people will
want to get it. People will want to live there.
So maybe he means half of the vacancies, the 1.4% of vacancies
are vacant because of rent control. But that doesn't make any
sense to me unless it's somebody trying to game the system.
>> Got a real bright future ahead of him. I don't know.
Hopefully he runs for something. I think he was an assemblyman
>> Hope he stops wearing those dresses. A couple of years
ago that this guy that made this video was going to become mayor
of New York. I wouldn't have believed it in a million years.
>> Yeah. Well,
>> it's good. It's good that you're recognizing that. Let's
take a look. Let's continue going. >> Housing doesn't have
to be seen as a market at all. In other countries, housing is
considered a fundamental right like education or healthare. That
means the government goes to significant lengths to guarantee
every rent control and the market plays a much smaller role in
the construction and distribution of >> So let's hop across
the pond and about 100 years back in time to take a look at just
one example of how an alternative housing model got started in
beautiful red Vienna. At the end of the First World War, the
AustroHungarian Empire collapsed, leaving behind a number of
successor states, including modern-day Austria, home to the former
imperial capital of Vienna, the fifth largest city in the world.
Despite being the seat of an empire, the chaos of the war and
decades of neglect, had left the working class of Vienna in desperate
circumstances. Inflation was rampant, jobs were scarce, social
services were non-existent, and hundreds of thousands of people
were crammed into decaying tenementss where overcrowding, disease,
and violence were ra. >> They always use Vienna.
Uh, I mean, it makes sense to me to use Vienna. I will say from
what I understand, Vienna is like one of the most beautiful cities
in the world. So, whatever they did, if you could emulate it
somehow, I don't know what you could take from them for
So it's no surprise that in 1919 at the first elections ever
held in Austria where all adult citizens could vote, the Social
Democratic Party swept into power at the municipal level on the
promise of dramatic social and economic reform. And they delivered.
The new government of Vienna implemented a huge range of services
including public health care and public child care. They built
high-quality hospitals, schools, and recreational facilities.
But their crowning achievement was an ambitious program of social
housing, what Americans call public housing that began in 1923
and saw 60,000 new apartments constructed in the first year of
its existence, built by the government and financed by Dude,
this is uh this is like the
Americans are like immune to this. Americans are like that's
socialism that's c that's communism that's like yeah no Karl
Marx Huff. So this is literally on like a socialist predicate,
right? that they're building these units. Like they're literally
like we're socialists. This is Yeah. Yeah. No, no, no, no. Like
Americans are immune to this. They think this is like always
depressing. But if you have cities with like engaging things
going on in them, you can do this and people will live there
and be happy. They will like you could you could just foundationally
say, "Hey, we we actually rent these things for like different
prices to different people and we're going to do a mix of incomes
and you you apply and you get in." And guess what? That's how
a whole bunch of things work in Europe, right? That's how I think
like Sweden works. A ton of like cities work like this. But realistically,
if the city is nice, if it's a nice big beautiful city, people
will apply. They'll live there. They will be happy.
But I think it's like they're small units. They're like, "Yeah,
everybody talks on the architecture and like the tiny little
units." It's like, dude, if you live in New York City, you're
not sitting your apartment the whole time. Who cares if it's
tiny? Taxes on. >> How' they do that without the profit
incentive? It's just so strange. I don't understand this. >> But
these weren't the kinds of apartments you might picture when
you think of public housing in the United States. Drab highrises
played by chronic neglect and underinvestment.
Residents could enjoy leafy courtyards, wide open spaces, and
plenty of natural light. They had shared, state-of-the-art kitchens,
food co-ops, bathousarmacies.
No, you know what's you know what's better than this actually?
Like a massive luxury mall at the end of co. Thanks, Mr. Cuomo.
Thanks, Mr. Cuomo. You're so great. Let's have a big luxury apartment.
That's what we need. A big luxury mall. Sorry, not luxury apartments.
A big luxury mall. You know, box stores like people shop at still,
right? That's totally a thing. Yeah. Box store. We need a big
mall. Let's go to a big [__] loser.
So good. Did they [__] up that mall, too? I mean,
the mall probably did get [__] up, but anyway. Electra
hall schools and swimming pools. these apartment. >> Why
is why are they not factoring in the the the
moral harm of of offering people housing at a at a cost affordable
level
and and how that actually makes them
>> It's a moral hazard. >> No, I'm not worried about
that. But brother, do we have enough money for everyone to have
>> I will hold on. I will say though, okay, just real quick,
I will say that Oh, also, couldn't you just couldn't you totally
just buy into people's like ego in New York City? Like literally,
hey, we're going to build this whole thing. We're going to name
it after like one of our investors. If you're if you're like
rich as if you're like Peter Teal, you could have Teal Park,
the Teal Apartments, the Teal Tenementss, okay, in New York City,
you could have the Aman
All Palestinians
complex, okay? the Bill Amanf funded kill all Palestinians complex.
It will stand for a millennia in the middle of New York City.
Okay, we'll just let you name it. You could do whatever you want,
Bill. Okay, we'll do
>> Have a house like this for 350 million people. You know,
we don't >> Oh, also I would say for this
>> I would just love to see how this looks now. These are
these are things like as they get fixed and they're all beautiful.
I would love to see the maintenance. I'm sure in Vienna things
are getting maintained. Europeans have a different like uh Europeans
have like a different thing going on than a lot of Americans,
but I would love to see in the modern day the sun is bad.
L we already we are we absolutely do. We absol freakingutely
do. Federal jobs
uh a a national initiative to build housing. Localize it if you
want. We absolutely do. 1 million%. So, you're going to do the
free housing. You're going to do Okay, we agree on health >> No,
no, this isn't free. >> So, the government bills it so
we all pay for it. We all have enough money. Well, we already
all have enough money to afford houses like this. Why don't we
just buy houses like this? >> Wait, what do you mean? >> Like
the What is the government? The government has our money, right,
in taxes. Collectively, we have to have enough money to build
houses like this. If so, if I was shown a plan where they said,
"Oh, >> so collectively, you don't have the money individually
to buy houses like this. You don't have the money to commit and
you don't have the money to build these things with a commitment
to having like mixed income tenants."
Yes, obviously scale is the big thing. That's why the single
family home, this wouldn't be like the single family home. And
I do think you could have this as like I think the way these
things function in Europe, you'd have to look into it for Vienna
specifically, but I do believe you like lease there and you do
get to live there and you pay the rent, right? But you are on
a lease. I believe that like you when you leave your lease is
up. You you go you don't get to like move out of Vienna and then
maintain your apartment, right? If you if you're leaving you
you have to give up your rent control [__]
I think this is how it's like tied to immigration. And it's tied
to everything. Oh, >> you can get all American people a
gorgeous house like this with pools and
>> No, no, no. This is like for big cities, Chank. This
is for really big cities. Massive cities. This the only place
you could do this. You need massive population density, a huge
tax base that you can tap into to actually invest in stuff like
this. Obviously, in Idaho, they cannot have this. They cannot
do this. This doesn't make sense.
>> ETA, right? How' they do it? >> Because they had
enough money. For whatever reason, they had enough. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Hold on. They had enough money, Chank. The extremely wealthy
and rich losers of World War I had a ton of money kicking around
to build this stuff. Yeah. Is that how Is that what we're trying
to Dude, they had so much money. They just had all the money
in the world. Are you sure? I feel like they didn't I feel like
they probably borrowed money. They probably didn't just have
the money to do this, right?
>> Money at that time to be able to do it. I feel like
they may they may have uh >> they may >> you talk
about Austria? Yes. The Austrohungarian Empire disintegrated,
right? Austria loser of the war. No, they might not have been
subject to the
the Tree of Mars. whatever whatever like totally bankrupted um
whatever totally bankrupted
Germany maybe they weren't subject to the same things >> have
had uh more of an initiative to actually utilize taxable revenue
in an appropriate direction because they seemingly had uh more
interest in solving this issue rather than subsidizing corporations
and the superw wealthy or even on the housing front offering
more and more tax uh breaks and
>> continuing the current uh private ownership structure
that we have in this >> But I want people to be clear.
>> Oh, so is the idea in Austria that the banks were private
and that the wealthy powerful people in Austria in specifically
in Vienna still were wealthy and powerful and could pay all these
taxes and really didn't get hurt by the war that badly that there
was just a ton of like private tax base there that still would
have been fine. I could see that >> clear about what I'm
saying. Remember, I hate the current system. The current system
isn't anywhere near ideal. >> Luckily, I know a place just
like that. It's called New York City. It's got Wall Street. All
the Wall Street people live there. It's It's just like that.
They've got a massive tax base. They've got all the money in
the world. >> It's corporate rule. Our government is completely
bought by the donor class. And so nothing we're doing now is
>> I didn't even think about the uh I didn't even think
about this is this is
in lifetime Austria doing socialist stuff. All right. You could
probably argue in some worlds that this is the environment that
fostered creation. Okay. Yes, you could you could actually do
this. You could probably argue this. I'm sure some people would
>> is anywhere near market. It's anywhere near rational
or logical. This is as corrupt a system as you could possibly
find. So if you're going to compare it >> I wouldn't say
I wouldn't say it's a corrupt system. I think it's the system
actually the most corrupt system in the >> Is the system
working as it's intended though cuz like >> intended by
who? For what? >> If if the goal is uh to to drive up profits
or the goal is to commodify housing which it is right then yeah
for capital owners this is this is not a bug. Is the system working
as intended? I'll give you an example. You're a homeowner. I'm
a homeowner. Right. For for many of us, uh, for for homeowners
such as ourselves, maybe houses are just to live in, right? But
for the overwhelming majority of homeowners, as you also described,
housing is is their their nest egg. It's their opportunity for
upward social mobility for their next generation. And it is uh
a an asset that you can leverage against, right? to take out
a mortgage or at least that's what people used to do before the
uh the the uh whole
interest rates uh went up, right? So, it's a retirement plan.
It's an asset. So ultimately for even with our lower uh much
lower home ownership rate in this country still a decent chunk
of Americans uh around 50% of Americans still look at this asset
that they own as
their their entire net worth as their
um as their entire existence basically as their retirement fund.
And that's the reason why if those prices were to deflate for
50% of the country who are wealthier on average, if not some
of the wealthiest in this country, this would be devastating.
And that's part of the reason why we never deflate the price
of housing in this country because because >> why would
we >> I don't really think like it's it would take a long
time for prices to actually deflate. Like there's just no
there's just no reasonable expectation that prices on housing
would deflate. It would just like it would stagnate as inflation
increases, right? >> You want to do that. So, look, so
this is we're having an enormously theoretical conversation that
isn't anywhere near reality today. >> No, no, no. But what
we're showing you, dude, Mike from PA, Mike from PA is in the
chat and he's typing up a storm over here because you need to
live in a house. You need a house to live.
Mike's going off in the chativings,
right? because Vienna is still uh implementing uh social housing
initiatives to this day. And not only that, but there are numerous
other examples where the government actually does control housing.
And the government controls housing in America too. We just do
it through property tax rather than just like having direct ownership
over land leases uh like they do in Singapore for example or
like they do in China for example. And then on top of that they
control flows of capital in China. >> But H do you see
what I'm saying by how theoretical it is? Because first we got
to get money out of politics so we can get our government back.
Like that's step one and we're not anywhere near >> I mean
you can just you could just have these policies you agree on
that like you could say this is my goal and I advocate for something
more fervently because I think it's a bigger deal. Like you saying
oh we have to advocate for something else first. You don't have
to do that. You could say oh I agree with this. I think it's
less important than my thing but yeah I don't actually you've
kind of convinced me on this that this isn't bad. Why do you
Some people think like there's a more important thing right now
and so they say don't do this but I don't see why this is like
you know in competition or in
uh which like um it doesn't it doesn't undo either policy like
you can they aren't contradicting you can do both of them at
the same time or you could you could believe in both of them
at the same time and just advocate for the one you think is more
important. I don't know why you do the well we we have to get
money out of politics first. No, you could get money out of politics
while advocating for this. You could use this as like a reason
you want to get money out of politics. People advocate people
who are arguing against doing something like this have no reason
to. Here's the
I understand why they won't bring up the land value tax, but
why does what does Jtock think of it? Land value tax. Uh I don't
mind the land value tax. I have heard of the concept of the land
value tax. I don't know how you do a land value tax.
H land value tax works in New York City. How does it work in
like the field of servers
that are generating massive revenues for companies for like someone
like Google? How do you like what how do you determine how much
money is being made from that for that land? Like I I actually
don't know. Is it just on the value of the land? Like then people
are making a ton of I don't know. I actually don't know. The
land value tax is something I don't understand particularly well.
I understand the concept. I think it's like interesting,
but
I don't know. I I actually don't know enough about it to be honest.
Like I would have to hear how some of the edge cases are handled
to be behind it >> Step one, >> I've heard that it's
like a less people think of it as a less regressive tax. I honestly
feel like a value added tax is way better than a than a land
value tax,
but I know that every progressive in existence thinks that's
wrong.
So I I just think the a value added tax is awesome. I think it's
way better. People are like, "Oh, well actually poor people can't
handle." It's like, okay, well, if you're too poor to go if you're
too poor to understand how to go and get a tax rebate, I don't
know what to tell you, man.
Sorry. I don't know. I don't know what to tell you, dude. >> Once
we get past [laughter] >> I don't disagree with you on
that. I I I do think that that's that's something that needs
to happen. I'm just But if we're talking about a world in which
cuz like you're not moving the needle in a more realistic direction,
neither am I in that in that situation because like we both agree
on that issue and that's a major hurdle. Um, and we're not talking
about that major hurdle right now. We're talking about a world
in which like if you had the opportunity to make this grand design,
uh, which direction would you try to move towards? And this is
what I'm saying. >> So, I'll tell you this. If we got to
this magical beautiful place, which by the way, I think we can
get to, although it's super super hard, where we get money out
of politics, we did a constitutional amendment, we freed the
country, right? Then what I would love is for Rhode Island to
try more public housing, for Nebraska to try more private housing,
and for everyone to try all sorts of different things. >> I
think they're trying public private housing in Nebraska. >> Yeah.
Right. They're not. But No, but you see my point. >> They're
trying private housing everywhere in this country. >> No,
but you see my point that I don't mind an experiment like this
at all in that in that better world, right? Where we've regained
democracy, right? And some places people will be a lot more right-wing,
a lot more leaning into the free market. some places
left. I don't I don't think right-wingers are right-wing because
of the free market.
>> I don't think so. I think rich right-wingers are right-wing
because of the free market, but I don't think right-wingers in
general. Like, you think West Virginia is what, plus 35 for Donald
Trump? You think those guys are like, "Hell yeah, brother. We
need more private. We need more private housing in this in this
state." No, they're just right-wing because uh of their their
economic stances and or their their economic standing, right?
Oh. Oh, okay.
And they've been pummeled by the Democrats or they feel as though
the Democrats are responsible because they're focusing on gay
rather than building housing for them. And the Republicans take
that's actually for Hassan [__] to lay it out like
that. That's actually shockingly aware. Like I I feel like I
don't check in on Hassan's politics a lot. He's normally He used
to be the guy who's like, "No, no, you have to focus. These are
people's lives." But he's like, "No, they're focusing on gay
instead of helping these people." Yeah, that's pretty much what
they think. Who care more about somebody being able to get trans
uh trans healthcare than about me being able to feed my family?
And I think that's a weird priority list. That's that's how people
in West Virginia think. Yes. >> Take advantage of that
weakness. Take advantage of their anger. And
West Virginia specifically, environmentalism is always going
to you. You're probably never getting those people back, right?
They all work in coal mines. There's ton of coal mining towns.
They've been propagandized against like climate change. If you
are going to run there on an environmental like platform where
you have to do like honest to god like necessary environmental
like regulation, you're probably just going to lose. Good luck.
>> And resentment and redirected towards gay people and
undocumented migrants and the like. >> So
there's two different things here, right? Right-wing ideology
and what do right-wing voters in America actually think, right?
And so we found out through Donald Trump that
all the that corporate media was telling us about right-wing
ideology wasn't really true at all. Oh, the right-wing voters
are all free trade. Are they? Uh, first of all, they didn't know
and they didn't care, right? And if they cared at all, I think
they were against it. >> Yeah. No. Yeah, they were they
were against it. I think like Donald Trump picked up a lot of
the the NAFTA resentment votes from a lot of like formerly unionized
workplaces and people that used to have like uh >> people
that used to work in in industrial output that no longer had
that job. >> Yeah. So, um I I think it's a little bit complicated
cuz people grew up >> right-wing inherently anti-free trade
laws. What? That's not true. Not inherently.
There's a shift that happened where a lot of like working-class
people have shifted or working-class or even poor people have
shifted to the Republicans because of their social rhetoric,
their like their culture war rhetoric. It doesn't have to do
with like their actual economic policies. Although some of the
act they do economic populism in some senses, it's almost all
just like yappy virtue signaling. Very very very little actual
economic populism coming from these people. They run on it. They
they talk about it a little bit, but it's mostly talk. It's almost
entirely talk >> on corporate media, especially the older
folks. So, if you're above 45, you got brainwashed so thoroughly
by corporate media that it's really hard to tell what you believe,
right? And what you were told that you believe like, hey, you
love Israel. Israel is a special ally, right? Our our government
is the best in
>> uh I think it's crazy that Hassan thinks someone from
Virginia or Arkansas don't see don't have a personal organic
Wait, did did you get I didn't get that impression.
Oh, are you saying because he paused and he said the like
the the their impression is is that what you're saying? Like
I think that's just to a lot of people. I don't know if you've
ever seen this. If you say these people don't think they think
Democrats want to trans kids, there is like 85 liberals who will
show up here and chat and go, "UH, HOW MUCH DID THEY RUN ON IT?
HOW MUCH DID THEY RUN ON IT? CAN YOU SHOW ME any ad of of Camala
Harris running on it? Does she want to trans? Does she she even
talk about trans people? Hello. Hello. Hello." He's probably
just trying to dodge those people who are incredibly annoying.
Right.
So, he's saying that to help himself to not have to get like
absolutely mobbed by a bunch of I think and that's that was my
impression, but you might be right.
The world it's number one, right? All this there's a million
pieces of propaganda you and I have both fought against and now
a lot more people fight against. Right. So, yeah, they might
some of them might have if you ask them in a poll, are you pro
for a free? They'll run on Republicans being racist all the time.
But most Republicans, okay, this used to be a little more true
like two years ago, three years ago, little little less true
now, but for a long time, Republicans were very silent on being
racist. But Democrats would always call them racist. And then
Republicans wouldn't come out and deny it. And you knew that
probably somewhere deep down they were a little racist. They
wouldn't come out and go, "No, no, no, no, no. We're like this
is no, it'll have no effect on these." No, they just were like
kind of silently racist, not really acknowledging it. Right?
That's like that's how it worked with Democrats and trans issues.
Yeah. You say you gave them up, but then when I say like you're
you're totally done. You don't care about this stuff anymore,
right? You don't go, "No, no, no. I don't care about that. I
don't want that." You go, "Well, I'm not talking about that right
now. Smells like to >> Betrayed. They might have said yes
back in 2008. Right. But in [snorts] in their heart, in their
when you actually push them on that issue, were they for it?
>> Well, that's the that's the same thing, Alien Mode.
I'm telling you that a lot of Democrats, a lot of politicians
probably do believe in a lot of those things. I don't think it's
wrong to believe in those things, but you have to assure people
that you're not going to like ignore the economy. You're not
going to take like stupid action in furtherance of some of your
principles that they that aren't in their interest, right? And
you have to message that way. But I I don't think there's been
a huge priority on that on like resetting the messaging. Like
I think Gavin Newsome was the first person who came out and said
this was really stupid for us to run on and I can't believe we
did it right.
But a ton like Camala Harris never did that. She never did that.
>> No, we agree. They were not for it. >> So like
when now when you take it to other issues, it gets complicated,
right? So if you said to an average right-winger today, are you
for the free markets? I think over 90% would say yes. Now, do
they really mean that? Well, it depends, right? First of all,
what free markets are we talking about? We don't even have free
markets. We have this we're, you know, government capture by
corporations. So we don't really like we don't have free markets
for drugs at all. We literally can't negotiate prices. It's the
least free market there is in the world. Right. So okay. So then
it gets super complicated as to what they mean by free markets.
But overall I take your point that they're not ideologues in
that way. Like if you give them a nice populist program in West
Virginia, they're going to say yes. West Virginia is not right-wing.
West Virginia is populist. Right. Same with Kentucky. I just
I I always say the racists need houses too and they need healthcare
too. And if you give them houses and then you say
big Michael Jordan fan, this guy, >> hey, like you're going
to have a house, but you know, cut it with this racist, they're
probably going to be like, >> you guys know that's a Michael
Jordan quote, right? That Michael Jordan got asked about some
like like, oh, hey, want to join this like political stuff? Do
you want to denounce this action by these by the Republicans?
And he's like, nah, man. Republicans buy Nikes, too. And then
he just kept doing whatever he was doing. Okay. >> Okay.
I I like that. I would rather have a house than be racist. There
will be some there will be some who will say, "No, I actually
do want to keep being racist, but ultimately it's class versus
politics for that reason." >> This must be where they pivot
to Fentes. I know they talk about Fentes. Speaking of trading
in racism just for a little economic populism, Nick Fentes made
a proposal. Trade proposal. I give up racism.
You give up Wait, what was the thing? Oh, immigration. Wait,
I think I He said identity politics.
You give up. We'll be We'll do immigration, but we won't be racist.
Okay, you can do DEI once we get rid of the illegals. Okay, illegals
out, then DEI, then we're all good. Okay, take care of the black
people. I'm not going to block that. But get rid of the immigrants,
we reset the economic table was I think Fentes's proposal. So,
>> um, but let's let's finish this video cuz he's going
to he's going to drive home this point real quick. Dude, I will
say Hassan picked the absolute worst video for Thanksgiving.
Okay, not like maybe not the worst, but like the old Mandani
video, bro. Talk about other stuff. Talk about some funny stuff.
I don't know. I didn't although I guess I didn't expect Cheng
to have this much push back. I thought Chen would show up and
just agree with this video. Like, he is a an economic populist.
This would be a part of an economic populist vision. You could
say, "Oh, well, the buying a house is what allows Americans to
to gain wealth." And and that is true to a large extent. Maybe
you let lower income people buy into some of these units. But
I'd say what you should do is you should let um maybe you have
to do that. I don't know.
I don't know, man.
To me, you got to you got to do something like this. This has
to be the approach in cities. >> The most beautiful argue
against the next mayor of New York >> to live in >> fostering
a sense of shared community among the people who lived there.
And the best part was that because the city didn't have to worry
about making a profit, just about paying off their maintenance
costs, these homes were both much nicer and much cheaper than
what workers had previously known. In 1926, the average rent
in vianese social housing was about just 4% of a monthly wage.
Yeah. >> The first 15 years after Austrian independence
saw its capital transform from a symbol of urban blight into
a beacon of socialist governance, it became known as Red Vienna
after the official color of the socialists who had pioneered
these changes. And even though Red Vienna fell in 1934 when the
country was seized by fascists who did what they could to roll
back social housing, that commitment to good, cheap housing remained.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Did that ship all get blown up?
Wait. Did this last for like 10 years and we just don't know
if it worked or not because it got destroyed in 10
>> Come on. What? Um, >> after the Second World War,
today an astonishing 62% of all city residents live in Social.
>> With the average monthly rent falling, >> how'
they do that? That's crazy. >> We're at between $400 and
$600 A MONTH. >> NO, that's Dude, Dude, that's crazy.
>> that's crazy. How' they do that?
Someone needs to put an end to this. They you know what they
need? [laughter] They need good >> the thing the thing
to make these projects work. You can you can make all these projects
work, but you need like a totally you need
just like the you know socialists who would have taken over this
city. You need like total ideological commitment that is almost
impossible in the United States. You need you need an unironic
new third position to get buy in from people. Hopefully not one
founded on anti-semitism. Okay. Hopefully not one so closely
associated with anti-semitism, racism, you know, the Aryan race,
but you need an unironic third position that you can like kind
of polish off, show is new, and and roll with or something cuz
I swear you just can't you can't get buy in on like the the capitalist
front, on just the pure open market front. You can't get buy
in on any of these fronts right now. You need but you need total
ideological commitment. You need people to think of this house
as like a symbol of who the country is. And you have to love
your country. You have to think of this as like a symbol of everything
you stand for. You have to take care of it. It is incredibly
important.
Third position is convert or die. Um well, I don't think convert
or die, but you need you need like ideological commitment in
these places, like hardcore ideological commitment from the people
living there, right? To make it
something if if a racist were here, this is why you have to have
a racist in the argument sometimes, okay? Cuz if a racist were
here, they'd go, "Yeah, so this worked for a while, but like
what's the diversity ratio in Vienna? What do they look like
in Vienna? They still eating?
Are there still Austrian braids in Vienna right now? You need
a RA?" Because most racists whenever they hear about social programs
will go, "Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, hold on.
Are they Are they totally a totally homogeneous group with no
racial animist at all?" And then they'll use that to break that
up. Okay? So I'm just saying >> good wholesome free market
enterprise capitalism not corporatism but capitalism that's what
they >> subsidies for lower income tax >> that is
a fraction of what people in America pay unlike in the United
States where public housing is treated as a worst case way to
house the very poor Vienna's social housing residents are extremely
diverse everyone except the top fifth of the population is eligible
to live in social housing this means there's broad appeal across
many segments of society which creates the foundation for for
its political popularity. That is how the majority of people
in Vienna enjoy something that's considered almost utopian here
in New York. Affordable housing that isn't just cheap, but desirable.
Housing that isn't just four walls and a roof, but a real home
with a sense of stability, safety, and community built in.
Oh, I see what you're saying, evil Johnny Bravo. Damn, you typed
up essays, though. But yeah, I get it. So you're saying that
when leftists do this, when they go and they like they they're
like, "Oh, well these people are actually like they're economic
populace. We can totally join with them." It's like you're fundamentally
misunderstanding who these people are at a foundational level
that like the racism is actually the racism or bigotry is actually
like foundationally important to them and they will vote that
way. And if you join a block with them, get ready for them to
really vote that way and they will they will support leadership
in whatever coalition you build who believe that same thing.
They'll be like, "Yeah, we'll put the racism to the side." But
they can't. They foundationally believe in it. I don't really
think that's possible. I I think people can be racist. I think
I I do think that for most people you you see that start to subside
at some point. Um
man, although I will say obviously uh the Western world is still
an experiment. Okay, this this American melting pot, the Canadian
like uh mosaic, these are experiments and we don't know that
they work yet. Okay, when push comes to shove, when there's actual
turmoil, is it just going to turn into prison? Cuz I can tell
you what happens in prison. Okay, in prison, they immediately
break down into ethnic groups and are at each other's throats.
What's going to happen in America or in Canada when the social
fabric starts to come undone? When the econ when the economy
starts to melt down a little bit? Okay,
[laughter] we'll see what happens. Do we automatically go?
We just going to automatically go, oh, race war. Race war. Now,
now, of course, this is this is actually Hold on. This is actually
how we build the next great society in America in like Earth
history. Okay? Whatever race, whatever race comes out of the
melting pot American race war is the strongest race is the master
race and they get to rule the planet and they take humanity into
the cosmos. Okay, that's what America is just setting itself
up. White people had to go down a little bit. White people had
to get down to the same like the same levels, okay, as everyone
else. And then there's going to be an economic crash and we're
going to have the race war and we'll figure out what race is
best. Okay, which race can do it? Only one example of an alternative
framework for housing. And Vienna has not fully removed housing
from the domain of the market. Residents still pay part of their
earnings in rent to cover operational costs and a sizable chunk
of the population lives in private housing. But it's an Listen,
I think a lot of people Latinos will win now, Indians would win
now. I think the the money would be on whites to win, but realistically,
whites are like kind of man, whites are like the older brother
doing like WWE moves on a younger brother. Whites have always
been at such a massive advantage. I don't know how we play from
like an even starting point. Okay, lots of people just be like,
whites, whites, white. No, man. We always we always had a techn
We had a massive advantage. We're basically unbeatable. We're
playing with cheats. Take the cheats off. What happens? Who knows?
actually existing alternative that shows us what a step toward
a better world could look like. If we want to end the housing
crisis, the solution has to be moving toward the full decommodification
of housing. In other words, moving away from the status quo in
which most people access housing by purchasing it on the market
and toward a future where we guarantee highquality housing to
all as a human right. So, how can we do it? We can start by making
sure people who access housing on the private market have ironclad
protections against abuse and exploitation. But to go further
toward the Vienna model, we'll have to go beyond the market.
We >> So, not only is the government a a major market competitor
that keeps prices uh relatively low, but there is regulation
beyond that as well. And some version of this exists not just
in Vienna, but like I said in China and Singapore and numerous
other places too. So, it's already being implemented in many
places around the planet. It's just unheard of in the United
States of America. It's like not even considered.
>> Yeah. So, uh first of all, they got all that free public
housing and it made them so soft they lost the war.
>> Well, yeah. [laughter] >> Yeah, that's what that's
probably what it was. Yeah. >> Okay. Now, in all seriousness,
so listen, I'm not opposed to it. In fact, I think that we should
study >> Hassan didn't like that joke. He just shot Ka.
You heard her cry in pain right there. God damn. >> Every
model out there. So, we should study the Finnish education system.
We should study the Norwegian prison system. We should study
how they legalize drugs in Portugal. And they're not all magic
fixes, but they're in interesting to incredible, right? We should
try we should study the
um what the what they did in Spain with uh >> I think these
guys studied it before they implemented it and have and their
existence or the continued existence of >> Don't be simplistic.
Just because it worked in Vienna, sorry, I don't mean it that
way. It's just just because it worked in Vienna doesn't mean
that it's going to work everywhere, by the way. But because it
worked in Vienna, it means that we should probably try it somewhere
else too, right? So, and see if it works. So, I don't mind all
of those experimentations at all. So, I'm not like to me when
you say public or private, I got no problems trying it in every
different way until we get to a system where we're super comfortable
what should be public and private. But again, we're not anywhere
near that conversation cuz right now our system is so, you know,
destroyed. two years ago, you would have probably said that we're
nowhere near u uh demanding a a complete >> uh back
a complete defunding of all uh all weapons transfers going to
Israel, things can change. My point is it's good to have a north
star and that's why I have no issue saying that this is my northstar.
This is what I'm working in the direction of instead of u instead
of conceding ahead of time. I like to think Chank thinks it worked
in Vienna because of racial homogeneity.
I mean, most people are going to tell you this and that's why
I say it's an experiment out here. Okay.
Can you
The issue is is you can constantly break people up and the focus
on like identity based voting blocks probably prevents anything
like this from ever happening.
Need to start to break that stuff down. Okay.
I don't know. I don't think you'll ever get buy in on on anything
like this if you have these like racial voting blocks constantly
working against each other's interests.
>> Uh knowing that, you know, there's going to be naysayers
no matter what happens. >> No, no. I think we could have
massive change. That's why I started Justice Democrats and I
mean we beat AO Crowley with AOC how many years ago, right? And
so do I think huge change is possible? Definitely. That's why
I started Rebellion Pack. That's why I started Young Turks. I
think enormous change is not only possible right now. in a moment
of of potentially awesome change, right? Then for me, that's
not the question. The question is how do you get there? And the
difference H and you saying that's your northstar, no problem.
That's great. There's nothing wrong with that northstar. It might
not be my northstar, but so what? Right. Uh so to me, what's
important is step by step, right? So we all got to now this is
where we could have the much bigger disagreement. I don't know
how you feel about it these Step one, throw Ezra Klein in prison.
>> Okay. Step two, question mark. Step
>> Seems a little excessive, but I'm willing to try it
out as an experiment. Okay. Just as an experiment, I'm willing
to give it a shot. >> Decommodified housing. I'm joking.
Ezra Klein, if you see this is a joke. Okay. >> Okay. So,
>> I think you are fine. >> Okay. But now, like the
way more controversial thing is these days, I think we should
>> He obviously thought it was a joke the whole time. who
unite with the right to defeat the establishment. So, because
we can't defeat them on our own and and if we unite, we can actually
win on Israel. We can we just kind of won on Epstein files. Uh
and we could win on we could even win on paid family leave. We
might even be able to win on healthcare because to your point
and to my point, West Virginia and Kentucky, they want healthcare,
right? They they don't want money in politics. They actually
agree with us on almost everything. They're anti-war anti-corruption.
>> I don't disagree with you. I think the major disagreement
that you and I have uh to a certain degree is and I say this
all the time that yeah, you need people if you want to unite
the people, you're going to have people you disagree with in
your move. >> They want healthcare, right? They they don't
want money in politics. They actually agree with us on almost
everything. They're anti-war.
>> So for evil Johnny Bravo, who's discussing this earlier,
[clears throat] Chank is Yes, Chank is Chank is very dumb. He
believes this coalition's on his side. Yep.
>> I don't disagree with you. I think the major disagreement
that you and I have uh to a certain degree is, and I say this
all the time, >> that yeah, you need people if you want
to unite the people, you're going to have people you disagree
with in your movement no matter what happens. The point is you
don't actually go to their side on, you know, social issues or
whatever. these things that are wedge issues that are used as
a distraction to make it seem as though the uniarty consensus
is actually not there on the issues that matter, the issues that
matter the most to every single person, healthcare, housing and
the like and foreign policy. But um but to make them come to
your side because you are offering them something, right? Offering
them free healthcare, offering them housing. Um and and that's
how you bring them to your side. I don't have a disagreement
there. I'm not saying like we just cut out, you know, whoever
has voted for Donald Trump and and shoot ourselves in the foot
regardless.
>> My my point is always that uh we bring them to our side
without having to concede on these other things. Like we don't
we don't concede on being unnecessarily cruel to undocumented
migrants or being unnecessarily cruel to trans people and constantly
talking about trans people this, trans people that. We just say
we just call it as it is. This is just a distraction. And I think
the Trump administration's failures on affordability after uh
winning the election against uh an administration that that came
across as as old and uh and unable to solve uh the one and a
half years of negative real wage growth that people experienced
under the Biden administration and the the inflation crisis that
people were experiencing. Um and then hyperfocusing
which is what the Trump administration did hyperfocusing on trans
issues and things like that. uh actually show people, actually
present a unique opportunity to show people like, "Oh, guess
what? Turns out it wasn't trans people that was making your rent
more expensive. Turns out it wasn't a Guatemalan migrant that
was the reason for why your healthcare is expensive." >> And
that's what I try to do all the time. So look, uh maybe it's
an issue of timing, but first off, uh on should they come to
us or should we go to them? It's kind of a false framing because
since we agree on 70% of issue,
I would say if this is true, then you voted left in the last
election, Moonray Murray. Like realistically,
I I always argue that the left didn't do a good job distancing
from these points, but you voted for like Democrats or something
because like the the left stopped focusing on it. did didn't
matter. Still got painted as focusing on it. Didn't matter at
all.
So I just I think most people cope. I think you probably just
don't like
>> Neither side actually has it going. >> But if
you're talking about traditional left-wing policies,
that's literally what I've been doing the last two years. I have
been saying yes to the right-wing who are coming to our traditional
policies. Right? So you're anti-war, that's traditionally leftwing,
right? You're anti-corruption. That's traditionally leftwing.
You're for paid family leave because you want more babies and
you want, etc., right? We want to treat mom American moms that
are great. That's traditionally leftwing. You want lower drug
prices, higher wages, all traditionally leftwing and I'm super
happy to take their alliance in it, right? And what I'm saying
is, okay, we just leave out the social issues in terms of our
debate uh when we're working together, right? So, we want to
work together on banning private equity from buying up our residential
real estate or we want to work on anti-corruption. What's up,
Ruby? How's it going? >> Okay, we'll argue about the social
issues later. And that's there's nothing wrong with arguing about
it and neither side has to concede at all. So, they could be
like, "Okay, I'm >> we're going to totally take over. We're
going to we're going to totally take over this government and
then we'll decide what to do with the black people >> Massively
anti-trans and we could >> I get it. I do get it. I feel
like that is probably how a lot of bad things come to pass. >> Be
massively protrans or fill in the blank. Muslim, Muslim, whatever
the category is, right? But if we let that stop us in the beginning,
we're never going to topple the establishment. And the establishment
is a bigger enemy to both us and them than we are to each >> So,
you see what I'm saying? >> Yeah, I do. But here's the
problem. >> Josh Holly is a great example of this, right?
Like I think there are or Tucker Carlson's a great example of
this. I think there are a lot of people who understand that left
populism, real populist economic uh policies are actually extremely
popular amongst the base right across the board. Regardless of
whatever uh ideology they slot themselves into, most people find
themselves in agreement with these policies. And the problem
for them is that they have a higher priority for either the nationalist
sentiment. and that's actually the goal that they're uh advancing
or the goal that they're working towards which is I think in
Tucker Carlson's case that's the point or or they're just lying
but they recognize the popularity of these uh left populist policies
and they're trying to maintain a base of support but when push
comes to shove just like with Josh Holly they will still be servants
of capital and that's the issue that I have with a lot of uh
the right and I think that's the issue that a lot of people have
with uh the self-described right-wingers, maybe not the right-wing
voters in general, because those people can be convinced and
move, but most people in positions of power within the right-wing
machine are either lying about being in favor of populism or
they care infinitely more about like implementing some kind of
insane nationalistic uh policies. All right. So, let's say uh
five different >> I mean I what what is the basis for like
not liking nationalistic policies or like or nationalist policy?
What is the basis for that? Does he understand that you need
like a shared? Here's the foundational thing. Human beings don't
work in the way where you can break them up into like
individual economic units, okay? and have them just believe in
nothing and and agree on nothing and then just all be like, "Well,
we agree on, you know, we want free healthcare. We're actually
the party that exists on free healthcare." You can't be that.
You need like a whole identity for people to
right? Nationalism trends to ethnationalism. Okay. Well, either
you can either you can subvert that and and keep it non-ethnationalist.
Was the USSR ethnationalist? I didn't think so. But maybe like
don't you just fundamentally not believe in anything if you think
the the USSR was like ethnationalist like like I I don't understand
cuz if you don't have some identity to get behind that isn't
race
then it will break down to race eventually. Okay. Then then honestly
this kind of organizing is probably never going to work in a
non-homogeneous society. You either you either believe that you
can do it as a non-homog homogeneous society or you don't. But
if you're trying to pass, if you're trying to do anything that
Hassan proposes, you need that buy in. You need some identity.
You need something to rally around. And it can't just be free
healthcare. Has to be like a way to explain the world. And if
it if it if you don't do that, I don't know. You're just kind
of
>> which listen, maybe it maybe it does work or maybe maybe
it doesn't work. I don't know. I don't have like a a strong opinion
either way. Did I just mute? God damn it. Losing shank >> some
kind of insane nationalistic uh >> All right. So, let's
take uh five different Republicans or right-wingers and and give
and I think that'll be help clarify the conversation. First of
all, I agree with you and that's the main point I make is to
make a differentiation between the leaders and the voters. Okay.
So, oh yes, hold on. Love the pie. That is something that can
bring people together.
That's a that's one a lot of people don't like though. That's
what a lot of people have that problem.
Okay.
Religion is one of the things you could organize on, but you
need everybody to believe in that same thing. That's probably
never happening either, but you need you need something there.
Or I don't know. You need I don't know. You need America. Like
patriotism used to unite America. It doesn't seem to
Doesn't even let right-wingers hang out in his chat community.
What makes him think they would buy whatever he sell wants to
sell? Uh, that's a good question. They almost certainly wouldn't.
I can't imagine any right-winger actually goes over to Hassan's
side.
Can't see it. >> So, attack the >> best you get is
the uh the third positionist. That's the best you get. Somebody
like Fuentes being like, you know what, I'll make a deal with
you guys. Blah blah blah blah blah. >> Leaders, politicians,
media, no problem. Right. That's the game we're in. Don't attack
the voters. You they actually agree with us on 70% of stuff.
Take yes for an answer. Okay. So, now when you get to the five
guys, so we all agree on a bunch of them. Mitch McConnell, corporate
Democrat, uni party, I'm sorry, corporate Republican, but really
what's the difference? So, like, we hate him. The right-wing
hates right-wing base hates him. So, we're past that. And that
used to be our number one impediment. Then you get to Steve Bannon.
Steve Bannon pretends to be the biggest populist on the right
wing. Like the the godfather of populism in a lot of ways in
the right wing, but I'm worried that he's utterly foolish. Right.
So, here he is behind the scenes. >> Hey, based on what?
That's That's >> He's working with Epstein doing a fake
wall, constantly scheming for power and more power. But >> like,
wait a minute. I >> Are you Wait, are you telling me this
this former Wall Street hedge fund manager is not trustworthy?
WHAT?
I totally trusted Steve Bannon with
What?
The The guy who used to work for one of the big banks, that guy
is untrustworthy.
No shot. Get the out of >> Thought you were against the
elite. >> You were for Goldman Sachs, right?
That's the one, right? I'm sorry. I know that because Oh, because
of uh Oh, what's the guy's name?
Uh infamous
infamous guy who got cancelled for being anti-Semitic was a nationalist.
Oh, Tucker Carlson talked about how he was racist. Why can't
I Huckabe? No, not Huckabe. Not Huckabe. Not Huckabe. That guy.
Buchanan. Papuchanan. Yes, thank you. Papuchanan.
[laughter] Apparently, that was one of the reasons you knew Pat
Buchanan was anti-semitic. Pat Buchanan would only talk about
Goldman Sachs and would never talk about Morgan Stanley. Okay.
>> And and and at every turn, it seems like behind the
scenes, you're actually helping the elites and you're using populism
as a way to get popular to do your actual agenda. So, I'm super
worried about Steve Bannon. Right >> now, you move to Josh
Holly. Josh Holly's got his foot in one in Mitch McConnell's
camp and he's got his foot in populism. He did actually stop
taking corporate pack money. So he's not 100% full of [__]
like the other guys like Ted Cruz, etc., right? So he's only
50% full of [__] now. So that's an improvement, but
at the end of the day, he's too attached to the old system. So
he's going to side with the McConnell of the world is my guess.
So not that useful, right? So now we're left with two guys that
are left. Tucker Carlson and yeah, I'm going to say the word.
Oh.
Oh, my soundboard isn't on for me. But
damn, here it comes. Uhoh. Left with two guys after Bannon and
Tucker Carlson. Wait, who's the last one? Wait, who's the who's
that last one? Who could that be? Who could that be? Uhoh. >> Or
the name Nick Fuentes. Okay.
>> I I have >> Oh no. >> Stopped censoring
that Nick Fent mentioned since he's getting profiled by the New
York Times, you know.
>> God, that's uh Could you imagine? Oh, nothing. I'm not
going to. >> So, Tucker Carlson, I think, has a shot of
actually meaning it >> and so I'm not sure that I agree
with >> You and I have had a private conversation about
this many years ago, and I think I've been vindicated on this.
Um I think >> I think I've been vindicated on it, but we
can have that conversation in a minute. Uh so to now >> I
just missed what he said by the New York Times, you know. >> Yeah.
So Tucker Carlson I think has a shot at actually meaning it.
And so I'm not sure that I agree with you. >> You and I
have a you that's Tucker Carlson has the lowest shot of actually
meaning it. Tucker Carlson is like the Iraq war guy who didn't
even say he was wrong in Iraq until like 10 years after he stopped
talking about it. First he just stopped talking about it so he
could not draw attention to it and then he just started yapping
about it all the time as if it was the worst mistake he ever
made. He's Yeah. He Tucker is like proto JD Vance. No wonder
they're so close, right? They see each other. They like have
similar sequence DNA. There's something equivalent about them.
No principles, no nothing. They just have to be where they have
to be. Okay?
I mean, if they're not CIA agents, they're agents on behalf of
somebody. We just don't know who their master is, right? I can
see you. I can see that you're an agent of some kind, but I don't
know who you serve. That's disturbing to me. >> Had a private
>> No, I don't I don't necessarily think it's Israel. I'm
not trying to hint at >> conversation about this many years
ago and I think I've been vindicated on this. Um I think >> I
think I've been vindicated on it but we can have that conversation
in a minute. Uh so to now you go to we'll come back to Tucker.
You go to Fuentes
and so he seemed to be a classic guy who's to be fair to him
not hiding his nationalism right
dude. No, the guy who remade his entire public image and changed
all his positions within the last three years is totally trustworthy.
And it's not even the first time he's done it is the funny thing.
Like go watch his CNN stuff from before. It's not even the first
total totally reptilian chameleon move. Okay? It's not even the
first one. If it was the first one, maybe you would have a reason
to trust him. But it's not the first one. It is in a is after
a long line of these
>> So he was like, I'm going nationalist. I'm going Christian
nationalist. white nationals. It appeared to me, right? That
was the original my original read of him. But now he's also changing.
And so now I know we're all
[laughter] Dude. Oh boy.
Dude, thank God. Thank god Nick is probably just too weird. Like
just a little too weird to ever get like true mainstream like
political appeal. I think he can have mainstream appeal as a
commentator. I think you have mainstream appeal in a lot of ways,
but probably never as a real politician. Cuz I swear to God with
like how Chank just totally bit like, "Oh no, Nick's really changed.
He's like changed at all." Bro, Nick Fuentes probably likes Stalin
because he knows in another life with a different upbringing
he could have been Stalin. Okay, he's like he's like one he's
like 1% away from being Stalin. I swear to God. Like he could
totally fool Chank into thinking he's like this awesome friendly
guy who believes the same thing he does and then Chank would
get two bullets in the back of the head. Okay, not just one bullet
in the back of the head, but two bullets in the back of the head.
I really think he's like kind of he's totally changing guys.
>> Cancel him to be Jesus and Okay, Barry Weiss, if you're
watching, which you obviously are holocaust denier, >> right?
So, no problem. You deny the Holocaust. You say all these,
[laughter]
>> dude. Chank one.
Here's the thing. Okay, here's the
I'm going to say it. I'm going to say it and it doesn't mean
anything about the regime that undertook it. Okay? The regime
that undertook it is monstrous. But nobody gives a about the
Holocaust anymore. Stop talking about it. Somebody denies the
Holocaust. I don't care. They're But I don't want them canceled.
I don't want them going anywhere else. It's a an opinion that
doesn't matter. I don't care about the Holocaust. Nobody should
care about the Holocaust. Guess what? It's time to forget. You
guys said never forget, but I want to forget. Let's just forget.
No more. No thank you >> things. He's against race mixing.
Well, I'm married to an Asian woman. What am I going to agree
with that? Right? So, obviously, we're against all that. But
even now, he has realized that's not actually where his audience
>> He's So, whether it's >> I just think like listen,
genocide denial while there is while there is like um while there's
blame left to to spread around, while there's still understanding,
you can denying a genocide is is terrible. It's horrible. Well,
societyy's trying to reorient and heal from that genocide. We've
reoriented from the Holocaust. We've healed. Everybody's moved
on. Everybody's been they've had their reparations. Everything's
been done. We can we can stop talking about it now. We all know
what happened. Yes, there will be a tiny subset of people who
don't believe it happened. I don't care. Nobody should care.
It is It is essentially only a weapon at this point. Anti-semitism
can still be a problem. I'll even say that. But you don't need
to talk about the Hol the Holocaust. the Hollywood cost, the
hol the Holocaust. Okay? You don't need to talk about that to
talk about anti-semitism. It just doesn't need to get brought
up anymore.
That's it.
Boom. Done. Close the book. Close the book on the Holocaust.
Don't
>> I think he's a grifter. I think these guys are all grifters.
>> Right. Whether it's Craven or not, >> and by the
way, that doesn't mean I'm cool with any of Nick's beliefs. It's
not cool. It's not like I'm like, "Oh, yeah. W the Holocaust
didn't happen." Nope. Holocaust totally happened. I know it happened.
I believe the story basically bar forbar with what's been told
to me. Okay. I just don't think it's actually useful. It's not
being used in any useful way to prevent people from doing anything.
It's only used as like a cudgel.
>> They're grifters or not. Even Fuentes is now saying
he said it just like two days ago. You know what? Maybe we put
aside the racism and the cruelty and the abuse,
right? which is an amazing admission by the way that that kind
of is the direction they were going right and he says maybe we
put that aside
just to be able to unite with the left I'm not saying yes to
Fuentes I'm just saying look at the tide moving the tide is moving
towards populism because it's being driven by the audience the
audience wants real populism so when they says
>> I don't the funny thing is is um I don't think chank
Is
slavery still brought up? Um,
sure. But, but black people haven't re taken their feet and slavery
wasn't the only thing. There's Jim Crow, too. So, black people
haven't been able to recover like broadly, American black people
in the same way that they've been able to recover. Okay? And
they have recovered. Okay? They have recovered. They got reparations.
They That's what I just said, by the way. Philip Oliver Philip
Oliver Holtz, that's what I just said. Got their reparations.
They literally got their reparations. Black people haven't. And
I don't know if they ever will, but like there there literally
is no more discussion to be had. It was acknowledged. It was
dealt with. It was it's over. Anyway, yeah. So, I think Cheng's
making an interesting point here, a goodish point, but also the
idea that he's like taking Fuentes on as a as a significant actor.
He has to make the differentiation of I believe there is there
is a group of people animating him and I like talking to those
people and I understand that Fuentes has some like bad some like
reprehensible beliefs but I don't want to be I don't want to
be removed from being able to talk to those people who I think
have legitimate grievances without or sorry by like totally discounting
this person. I do think he's racist. I do think he has these
beliefs. I don't think he's changed them. But I do want to talk
to him and thereby his audience because I think there are people
there who aren't lost.
I don't think
Yeah, I don't know, man. I
I don't know how to approach it cuz like in a lot of ways I think
Nick's a grifter, but I don't think he's a grifter. Like he's
not a grifter in the way that like he's he's taken like the most
expeditious like money-making route. He's not. Right. Nick's
done Nick got cancelled. He's like he has actually stood on business
for beliefs that realistically like there was no discernable
future in standing on business for, right? Like outside of that
one big donation he got from the French guy, I don't even know
if he was making that much money. I don't think he was making
that much money. So like yeah, I don't know that meme of Charlie
Kirk being the damn that held back Nick and then super soldiers
will become marketkedly less funny in a year.
Well, it wasn't just Charlie Kirk who was hold Oh, man. Charlie
Kirk was successful in doing that because Charlie Kirk never
talked about it. Charlie Kirk went around in private. He never
ever It totally violated his publicly stated principles, right?
What he did to Fuentes completely and entirely. It was a complete
like disgrace based on the principles he he claimed to have.
Oh, we can talk to anybody with any ideas except this guy. We
can talk to anybody with any ideas, no matter who they are, except
this guy, right? and he never said it publicly. He wouldn't talk
about him publicly. He would always go behind the scenes and
say, "Don't don't collab with this guy. Don't talk to this guy.
Don't be around this guy." So, I don't know. Um,
he was he was kind of the damn, but he had to be silent. All
the people now who are like, "Cancel this guy, I don't think
you can do that anymore." Also, the people now who think Charlie
Cooks Charlie Kirk stood for like free debate, like freedom of
expression and stuff, he obviously didn't. In fact, the thing
he he literally risked it. Every time he tried to cancel
every time he tried to undercut undercut or or stop somebody
from talking to Fuentes, he risk getting exposed as like a total
hypocrite. So, I don't even know how right-wingers actually say
this is Charlie's like principle. No, it's not. It never has
been. It literally never has been. >> They don't want it
and they're pushing in a better direction. So, what >> Oh,
I got to pull it back for the start of this. >> You guys
are all grifters, >> right? Whether it's Craven or not,
whether they're grifters or not, even Fuentes is now saying,
he said it just like two days ago. You know what? Maybe we put
aside the racism and the cruelty and the abuse, [laughter] right?
Which is an amazing admission, by the way, that that kind of
is the direction they were going, right? And he says, "Maybe
we
[laughter]
Hold on. Hold on."
That's one of those things. That's one of those things where
it's it's the same as when they stop talking about the JQ for
a long time. Those communities, it it literally is the exact
same thing, okay? In a lot of ways, they know they're cruel.
They know they're mean. They just know there's no like advantage
to talking about it. And they all agree they should be cruel
and mean to those people. They do actually all agree on that.
So, you don't hear it or you hear it as like an admission. He's
not admitting to something that people are going to go, "Oh my
god, you're evil." He he's admitting it to in like a way of like
guys I know that it's like totally righteous to call these people
these trans people to like point out their their right to talk
about them roping to to do this. I know it's totally cool to
be cruel all the time. But but maybe we should stop for just
a little bit. Just a little bit. And but all of them agree that
that's funny and cool and awesome. They don't think it's like
bad and oh it's actually like a secret thing we don't really
acknowledge and we're actually ashamed. No, it's awesome. and
they're like, "Well, maybe we should stop doing it just to fool
these guys for a little bit." That's like more where they're
coming from. >> we put that aside just to be able to unite
with the left. I'm not saying yes to Fuentes. I'm just saying
look at the tide moving. The tide is moving towards populism
because it's being driven by the audience. The audience wants
real populism. So when they says they don't want it and they're
pushing in a better direction. So well and also the audience
can be directed and once somebody like Fentes has his legs in
this current environment. I do not believe you can actually get
him like off his feet
almost at all through through the normal means. So you can't
just say, "Oh, he's racist. Oh, he's mean." You can't do that,
right? The way it works is when when somebody comes along and
they're like, "Yeah, we should do economic populism, but also
like Israel is our greatest ally. We should do economic populism,
but like Peter Teal should get to keep all of his data centers.
And we should do economic populism. Like when they have like
a clear butt that cuts against all of the other positions, Nick's
Nick's there to go wrong, wrong, and here's how you're wrong.
Wrong and here's how you're wrong.
It happens every single time. Yo, Sage Mage, thank you for the
sub. Let's go. Seven months. What's up?
Yeah, it just goes like wrong, wrong, wrong.
So you the more you have these like grifting people and and actual
grifters who are like who are there with an actual interest I
people like Tucker to be honest with you. Did you add the hour
earlier? No. Are we running out of time? No, I haven't added
the hour yet. We got 16. What is that? That's 80. So it's two
hours. We can just add the two hours now cuz we'll go to the
Tucker and Pure stuff after this. I do think Tucker's an obvious
grifter. Tuck Tucker's like and not necessarily in the populism
stuff to be honest with you. not necessarily in the populism
stuff, but he is an obvious grifter on like whatever happened
with Russia. That's crazy. That's like something that should
never be forgotten ever in a billion years. Like, and the fact
that his shopping trip was being pushed onto other right-wing
influencers by those actual tenant media people. Yeah, that's
cooked, bro. You can't look at that. I understand Tucker's not
involved there, but Tucker's clearly deeply involved. For some
reason, they produced this piece and then all of the Russian
the actual Russian agents tried to push this piece onto other
influencers around them.
Like there is no question about Tucker's allegiances. Tucker
is total
Like actual maximum grifter. Okay. Anyway, I got to reset the
uh what do you call it? The the meters. We got to reset the meters.
Let's hit play. >> Why is Tucker Now, let's go to the heart
of it. Tucker, right? I Why is Tucker to me today different than
he was on Fox News? Because on Fox News he worked for corporate
media and he says it now himself. He says, "Yeah, I mean there
were certain things we were allowed to say, not allowed to say.
I regret a lot of the things that I said on there." So now he's
more tethered to the audience than he is to Rupert Murda. And
so he tries to serve his audience better. And now he says wrong
about Iraq.
>> Dude, it's like the worst. It's the worst catch 22.
The only people who tell the only people who will tell people
what they want to hear are independent media. But the people
who are really good at telling people what they want to hear
are the people who are totally comfortable and not at all adverse
to just lying to people, right? Telling them they the things
they don't want they need to hear. Sorry, they they want to hear
but not the things they need to hear. So you you like almost
guarantee
it, John. You almost guarantee that you can't actually get political
opinions from somebody who takes you seriously or somebody who
like cares about you because anybody who cares about you would
tell you the truth just like uh our our dear friend Tactical
Templar says. Okay, I love you. Okay, I actually love you Pokemon.
So, I'm going to tell you the truth. You're a vapid useless.
Okay, stupid buying yourself a ring. It's like that. Like that's
what people need to be told. But nobody is going to tactical
Templar the American populace. They're going to just be the simps,
the tier three simps in the chat just being like, "No, no, tell
me more. Tell me more. Tell me more about We have T. We need
TN, Mr. Fuentes. Tell me more. Don't forget the aliteration."
I don't I don't remember the alliteration. Okay. >> Right.
Wrong about war overall. Wrong about a bunch of >> Oh,
are you talking about the the slurp? Good lord. >> Right.
And by the way, have a lot of us on the left said as much as
he has about all the things we're wrong about, right? >> No,
I don't I don't say that at all. >> See? Oh, >> whoops.
Whoops. Never mind. Not that.
>> What my point is he's right and we're wrong or anything
along those lines. But he's at least making movements
to go towards agreement. >> You're saying that there's
a broader trend line that's uh moving in the direction of left
politics.
And that is the and that is the reason. >> No, he's he's
literally never once said left politics. He's never said that.
>> Why the likes of Tucker Carlson are are retriangulating
their messaging. That's somewhat understandable, but I do think
>> you imply there are not normal way there are not normal
ways to get Fuentes off his feet. Oh, you could like totally
deplatform him or like he's fearing right now. There's there
are kinetic methods to deal with him. Okay, which I don't want.
I obviously don't advocate for. I don't think it would even work.
I think that would lead to really bad [__] happening.
Okay,
but that's what he's hinted at. There are obviously like like
uh nefarious ways to get him off his feet. Would you deplatform
him at this point? Um,
yeah, you could get him off the mainstream platforms. He would
fade away again a little bit. It would be difficult. He would
make a lot of personal money, but his influence would drop massively.
Okay, so he would be personally enriched, but his influence would
drop off massively if he couldn't put his stuff out through Instagram
reels direct to people. Okay, this is what happened to Andrew
Tate. Andrew Tate didn't get like he didn't really get like truly
No, he did actually eventually, but like once you take them off
of everything, they they just fade away. Andrew Tate made a bunch
of money off his cancellation, but it won't matter, right? Eventually
the influence fades. People don't have a long enough um
attention span. I think that um ultimately I don't necessarily
care for Tucker Carlson personally or Nick Fuentes, but I do
care about changing the mindset of their audiences
because I
social
uh socially regressive politics to be uh and reactionary politics
to be uh a distraction and that anyone that does that to any
degree is
inherently
and and uh deliberately doing this because they want to move
people's attention and focus away from the material inequities
that they are facing and away from a steadfast approach to dealing
with those problems. That is the reason why it's very easy for
me to say all right-wingers in general are grifters. And even
that moderation that they're engaging with is them simply reading
the room and recognizing that they have to offer some kind of
what you call populism. Uh some kind of left-wing
uh material solutions.
Uh some of which let me say two things about some of which do
it because they want to maintain their popularity. some of which
do it because they have a higher degree of priority for like
nationalist fermenting nationalistic sentiment and they think
this is the most um effective way of doing it. I mean Adolf was
uh in charge of the national socialist party right because at
the time socialism was a very popular movement at a time when
liberalism was failing just as it is now. um fascist movements
uh were were uh presenting themselves as revolutionary movements
or an alternative to socialism that Oh, I said I said kilo wasn't
gone for 2 hours. There's no way you're working out for 2 hours.
Okay, because categorically you Hold on. Oh, imagery won't load
if it's on a VPN. So stupid, dude. One second. Categorically
real quick.
What did it take you 60 seconds to start a set? That is technically
2 hours and 1 minute, but you weren't working out for two hours.
Unless you were literally literally in chat from the gym, you
you said this and you started benching immediately.
Off.
No shot. You lift for two hours, you don't lift hard enough.
Um, it depends on what you do to warm up and what you do after.
You There are people who do like really volumeheavy work. Um,
blank. I don't know how he works out, but there are people who
do a lot of volume heavy work,
right?
Anyway, that wasn't as scary in Mussolini's Italy. It was uh
it was bringing about a synthesis as uh he would call it of of
socialist sentiment but also uh protecting the petite bourgeoisi.
Okay. So, look, me, you, and maybe whoever it is that we want
to assign as the avatar for nationalism, who you think it's Tucker,
maybe it's Fuentes, maybe it's Megan Kelly. I don't care. Right?
My point is we might all have different agendas for what happens
once we get out of the woods, right? Once we break out of the
prison, to use a couple of different analogies, but we got to
break out of the prison first. And once we break out of the prison,
you want to go towards more socialism. Somebody wants to go towards
more nationalism. I want to go towards democracy, free market,
dude. Uh man, I need to study the uh the fall of the Weimar Republic
more. Okay. Because is is is Shanka just laying out the exact
reasoning that happened at the end of the Weimar Republic. All
we need to do is overthrow these people. It doesn't matter who
wins after that. Maybe the fascists win, maybe we win. [laughter]
Maybe this guy wins, maybe we win. One crystal locked later.
>> Markets, etc. Right. So, okay. But first, we got to
break out of the prison. So, so if you say to me, "Hey,
>> yeah, I don't I really don't get it. Evil Johnny Bravo."
Like I don't understand what they think they're organizing under.
There is no unifying principle. They're just like, "Oh, you'll
all become communists." That's like that's literally all all
he's saying is is you'll all become communists. You'll just love
Marx and Mao as much as I do. Like no. No, that's not happening.
God. So, what's your underlying like principle? What's your underlying
like ideology that you all share?
Hank's trying to get through with the coalition of totally antithetical
ideologies. We'll see if he can pull it off. Let's say take Tucker.
He has an hidden agenda and it's nationalism. >> And he's
not even hidden. >> Yeah. Okay. Whatever. And he'll say
to you and you don't, to be fair to you, you don't hide that
your your northstar is more socialism, right? >> Yeah.
Because because there's a difference between those two concepts.
>> Yeah. I get it. >> One is good. The other is uh
an incredibly deadly self-defeating
>> Yeah. I don't I don't love socialism.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Fascism has failed
everywhere it try. It's been tried. Nationalism has failed everywhere
it's been tried. Unlike the thing that I believe in. [laughter]
There's no way. There's no way that you could say that with a
straight face. Chank's like trying not to kneel on him so badly
right now. Are you serious? YOU'RE A COMMUNIST AND YOU'RE SAYING
THIS? ARE YOU SERIOUS RIGHT NOW, HASSAN? COME ON, MAN.
>> And again, it depends on what we mean. If we mean Northern
Europe, then I kind of do love socialism. If we mean like >> no
nor you know Venezuela then no I don't love socialism and I get
it. I don't want to get into that. >> Socialism is an economic
organization of uh socialism is a different organization of the
economy. Um Venezuela and and Norway actually have uh not even
comparable degrees of socialization or
Norway actually has a higher degree of nationalization. this
entire extraction industry is nationalized as opposed to Venezuela
that has a lower degree of
>> I don't see like how people, by the way, people argue
against nationalization and stuff. And I don't see how you can
see Norway existing with their oil extraction industry and say
that it can't be done. It can be done. People just don't want
to do it. The political will isn't there to do it, but it can
be done. It absolutely can be. >> Yeah. Like naturalizing
your oil reserves, by the way, is a super interesting idea. So,
that's what I'm But that's like the the difference there is of
course the way that uh the the
capitalist uh hegemonic superpowers have treated uh these countries.
Norway is very close in proximity or was very close in proximity
to the USSR. So the threat of a good example from the USSR was
what allowed a lot of these uh Western European countries uh
to continue a degree of socialization because they were conceding
just like you're saying Tucker Carlson is conceding to us on
a lot of these
uh the the capital owners there were conceding out of fear that
if they don't concede at all then then they are going to become
communist and that the European countries are going to snap into
revolutionary communist movements. >> So I got you but
what I'm saying hos is uh so socialism we can have a great wonderful
debate about how mixed our economy should be and whereas nationalism
goes towards authoritarianism
and I'm never going to agree to authoritarianism. So I get it.
I get that they are not the same and I I get that even though
I'm >> Dude, now they're both sweating. How hot is that
room? They're both They're both sweating so badly right now.
>> Might not agree with either. I'd rather lean to one
side than the other for sure cuz I don't want anything to do
with >> What do you mean by that? Authoritarianism. Like
socialism leading to authoritarianism. >> No. No. Nationalism
leading >> Nationalism leading to authoritarianism. >> Yeah.
Nationalism almost always leads to authoritarianism. Well, it's
because it's because you have to eradicate like nationalism or
fascism has a ingroup outgroup dynamic.
>> Dude,
that how can they say these things with a straight face? Have
you ever read like a single piece of Chinese literature
that isn't produced by actual
that's described like a struggle session and [__]
before? Like, let's be real. Let's be let's be so for real right
now. Um actually communism has no ingroup out
>> And and there are uh inalienable
characteristics that must be exised forcibly
from >> What have you been saying about >> What have
you been saying about the party, comrade? What have you been
saying about the party? >> Of course, that is the reason
why it has to be violent. >> That's why I'm never going
to agree with nationalism. That's why I'm saying that's why I'm
on the left. So I'm closer to you than I am to a nationalist
by a lot. Right? Because nationalism is, you're right, is either
white or Christian or by the way it could be in a different country,
Muslim or
>> Bro, are we pretending that the Chinese Communist Party
is not a nationalist party?
What what part of nationalism do they forgo?
They don't even forgo the racism
>> or black whatever. But it's
by definition. non-white nationalist movements have usually been
in the global south or at least historically have been uh uh
liberation movements in general like panarabic nationalism, pan-African
nationalism. These are not the same as
>> like the nationalism that uh you see in uh nationalism
is is
uh understandably something that people uh hate and despise because
it's in Western Europe or in America. It's the it's the inroup
that wants more domination and not uh the dominated populations
emancipatory movement. Like I'm not going to I don't think you
would disagree with like the FLN or something like Algeria uh
the the decolonial initiatives in Algeria would be considered
nationalistic
>> they take over, right? So like if they so whoever's
in power point you have a nation state. Exactly. >> Yeah.
Whoever's in power, if they're the majority and they do exclusionary
nationalism, then obviously I'm going to be against it because
I'm inclusive, not
>> why is Geogesser 100 million? Cuz it's uh
because it's never happening. You know, it totally can stream
when we do Geoger. That's why >> I'm going to pee real
quick. We'll we'll finish this video while I go pee and then
you can uh talk to the chat. establish community land trusts
to gradually buy up housing on the private market and convert
it to community ownership. We can give tenants a right of first
refusal to buy out their landlords when buildings go up for sale.
And we can fully commit to a new era of social housing, ending
subsidies for luxury housing development and using our wealth
to build Dude.
Dude, this is worse. This is worse than what he did to NMP.
Hey, why don't you just watch the mayor of New York City in a
dress do this stuff real quick? He's going to he's going to do
a little video for you. This is worse than what he did to NP.
Okay,
you want to see you want to see these musical people check it
out. Play walk away. Uh, hold on. Does the Hassan laugh for you?
Also, Hassan is bad. Asan is bad. Han is bad. Asan is bad. Asan
is bad. Hassan is bad. Asan is bad. Asan is bad. Asan is bad.
I'm not doing anymore. >> Beautiful, highquality social
housing projects that offer good homes and strong communities
to everyone. We won't decommodify housing overnight, but we know
what we have to do. And we have history to guide us. And we know
how we'll get there. Through a movement of the multi-racial working
class organizing for the better world we know is possible. This
guy get handed a script by Steve Bannon or
multi-racial multi-thnic multiclass populism. Workingclass. Sorry,
not multi-class working-class populism. Multinational or multi-ethnic
multi-racial multicultural
working-class populism. Multi- multi-ethnic multi-ultural
working-class populism. Yeah, civic nationalism. Let's go. And
we've already begun. Well, I got the white guy comb over cut
going on right now. I don't know. I assume he just spent enough
time in like the most concentrated
position of whiteness, being like the whiteness coordinator for
the anti-whiteness coordinator for the DSA that he just he was
in the whitest place ever. So, he slowly over time became
actually white himself. It started to seep into the DNA. Why?
He looks like Pisco here. He always looks like Bisco. I pointed
this out multiple times. It's the eyebrows.
>> I'm Zaharan Mandani, assemblyman for New York's 36th
Assembly District in Atoria, Queens for the Grall Institute.
>> All right. Uh >> oh, that was the Gralla Institute.
I thought people were joking. It is just the Grall Institute.
Okay. Yeah, he's got the voice for it. >> By the way, guys,
um Young Turks is turning 20 online. Um so December 21st,
uh is our 20th anniversary on YouTube.
>> And, uh, we, uh, so we'll do something on air on the
22nd, which is a Monday on December. Uh, but it's kind of neat.
We're the first YouTube partner ever. Uh, so we're the that makes
me the original YouTuber. So, uh, we're turning 20 uh, in that
regard. Uh, we also had three years on radio before then. Uh,
but uh, >> dude, it's so funny that like
it's so so so difficult to be a how would you put it? To be like
a consistent like off-the- cuff great speaker. It's so difficult.
Chank sounded like stardust right now for real. Okay.
Which is just very goofy. There's like certain
Most people can't just do it on any topic, right? They can't
just rattle off on any topic. But this is particularly bad from
Chen. It's kind of funny. But he's like not like this when he's
talking about politics. When he's talking about stuff he knows
he's just trying to do his plug right now, right?
It's Thanksgiving. He's probably had a few drinks. He has had
a few drinks. He was kind of stumbling when he first walked in.
>> We uh so we'll do something on air on the 22nd, which
is a Monday on December. Uh but it's kind of neat. We're the
first YouTube partner ever. Uh so we're the that makes me the
original YouTuber. So uh we're turning 20. uh in that regard.
Uh we also had three years on radio before then. >> Uh
but uh
it's
>> I'm just saying it's funny cuz he is uh he's a little
>> kind of neat like that. >> And it's kind of interesting
to see the evolution of all of us here. >> I would assume
I would assume Chen is Muslim, was raised Muslim. Yes, Hassan
was raised Muslim. Like he says he's culturally Muslim. I don't
know how sincere Chank's beliefs are. He did talk about he talk
about like women being so hot in Miami he wanted to rap them.
Seems Muslim to me. >> That's right. And I'll tell you
like from my experience having been here since kind of the beginning
of time when it comes to online video and the >> Chank
like that dragon at the end of Skyrim for real. Okay. Chank just
like that dragon at the end of Skyrim. Okay. So what doesn't
it mean so much more to become to to avoid evil against one's
nature? That's Chank. is that this is a >> Wait, that is
what Chank said, isn't it? I thought that was his essay when
people talk about how Chank wrote like a manifesto or something.
I think he's basically like, "I had a hard time controlling myself
cuz the women in Miami were so hot or something,
right?
Am I Am I corre I think so? I'm pretty sure that's real. I'm
pretty sure that that like people joke about Chank doing two
things. One I think about I think was another one, but I forget
which way which way that went or what comment it was. He did
some essays and one of them he commented on how he could barely
leave the women alone. But it's like it's a comment in like in
your internal monologue it like makes sense I think. I'm pretty
sure I know what I'm talking about. I'm pretty sure >> moment
we're finally getting to a place where people are becoming populist
and are beginning to realize how corrupt the whole system is.
And I I'm actually I've never been so excited. So, all right.
To to finish the thought, >> what you say populist, I say
is uh is is class politics.
>> that's okay. >> More and more people are are self-identifying
as socialist than ever
>> Yes. We're going to wrap up in a second. More and more
people are selfidentifying as socialist uh uh in comparison to
years prior. And I think that that is >> is is good cuz
populism is too
>> um populism can go in either. >> Oh, did did Hassan's
audience go back in the chanks giving archives and like wait
said he was like a socialist before this? Why is he not saying
socialist? Yeah. No, Hassan was sweating a lot before we commented
on this that they're both sweating. Okay. Chank came in, he was
sweating, then Hassan started sweating.
Thanksgiving. Hassan get pressed again ongsiving. Damn. >> Direction.
It just means that you're like anti-neoliberal. You're anti-establishment.
That's fine. I'm anti-neoliberal. I'm anti-establishment.
But I think I I call right-wing populists sloppilist for that
reason where it's just like fake populism. >> No, but don't
do that. So, number one, their voters aren't fake. They actually
do want the same things we want. They appear to be going to the
left, but they're actually in the same >> I think the funny
thing is here. I think Chank might have it precisely inverted
that like I think it's possible with a lot of the populist figures
that they actually aren't racist. With Tucker specifically, I
think it's entirely possible to me that Tucker's not racist at
all, that he doesn't have a racist bone in his body, but he hints
at identity being important, white identity specifically. He
hints at all of these things to signal to that audience. It's
the exact opposite. He is signaling at the audience without sincere
populist beliefs. He's sincering a or he's signaling a racist
belief, like some sort of race-based beliefs, right? I I think
I think Chanks like got it exactly opposite. It's very funny.
Like, listen, the the audience isn't racist. They're just like
populist. They're just looking for economic populism. It's like,
no, no, no. Like, the the commentators are signaling the the
racist leanings either to subvert the populist movement or or
possibly um to get in on populism the same way. like like sorry
to to talk about their populist ideas with like a lens of race
>> same place they always >> honestly I could see
that being the Fentes story possibly right >> the only
way the only way to overcome capitalism is to be veheently anti-semitic
he pondered the orb okay 15 years ago when he was like 13 he
pondered the orb and he's like I'm going to have to fight the
he knew it was one of those things it's just the establishment
lied to them corporate media lied to them and told them oh no
you don't want you know lower drug prices you don't want higher.
>> And by I obviously mean the inherently bad and harmful
not ethnically tied
Zionist lobby in America. Okay? Not tied to an ethnicity, just
unfortunately people being overprotective of their own ethnic
group. Okay? Understandably so in the wake of the Holocaust and
that this this whole organization has overls uh usefulness. It
has started to become harmful and for the sake of everywhere,
Nick Fuentes had to take it out. Okay? He had to do it. He had
to take it. He had to take it out. But but he did it for the
Okay. His first crush in high school was a boy. All right. And
he had to do it. He had to save the from themselves. The Zionist
thing. This is going to get you guys in a lot of trouble. We're
going to have to take this out. Okay.
And he's he's doing it in a way where he will be martyed after
the fact. What a hero, right? He will be he will be taken out
as like the the racist evil guy who pointed out all the flaws
but he was racist and evil
and I don't know this this fanfiction's gone a long way and I
don't have anywhere else to go with it so I'm just going to hit
play on the video >> wages and they did all that propaganda
look last thing on the nationalism is look Zionism is nationalism
and it it's a disaster because it means by definition you're
not one of us so you get less rights you get less everything
and so I'm not going to in favor of that. But >> Zionism
is not an emancipatory movement. That's why it's not it's not
emancipatory nationalism. Not that this the distinction is important
for history, but we're not even talking about that right now
anyway. >> Yeah. So, but my point guys to everyone including
youas and Tucker and everybody is let's get to our disagreements
after we win. So, after we win, you go towards socialism. Whoever
wants to go towards nationalism go that way. We'll split up and
we'll have beautiful arguments and debates and all of that stuff.
But let's take down the prison guards first. The establishment
are the prison guards. They're the maintainers of the corporate
system. So, let's knock that down first. Let's unleash populism
on both sides.
>> oh, also the Neils though, like Fuentes would just be
too obvious to target. I have no doubt that Israel has people
in the US. I have no doubt that a lot of countries have killed
people in the US to be honest with you.
Like realistically,
there are a couple countries who operate in clandestine ways
across the planet. Like China's almost certainly killed people
in the US. Like that would have to be true obviously. Iran Iran
literally hired people and sent them to the US to kill Donald
Trump, right? >> And then let's go have elections. >> Well,
purportedly. >> Then let's figure out what's more popular.
Let's have democracy. I just don't um I think that historically
speaking given that
um socialism is u an abolition and reconstruction of uh the capitalist
hierarchy whereas fascism is actually a mechanism of control
to reassert the capitalist hierarchy.
This exact dynamic that you're talking about has uh played out
in the past with fascist winning um when liberalism is failing
and and I I don't know evil Johnny Bravo. I really don't. Okay.
Would you describe Would you define Chank's take here as accelerationism?
He he this or sorry, this seems explicitly anti-strategic.
I mean, it does seem like acceler like
it's sort of
we need we have the same enemy. This enemy is going to prevent
us from ever moving forward. We have to destroy it and then move
forward without it there. This is like you you just have so many
examples in history of this exact method of thinking like totally
breaking countries totally breaking countries sorry countries
states uh empires right
like it's it's crazy
we just need a power vacuum a power vacuum always leads to the
best and most righteous actor taking power right >> and
contradictions worsen >> and people recognize that
>> um they need they are desperate for new
most people uh or not most people but capital owners who still
have uh their their remaining
crumb of power power will then align themselves with
>> So I think that there are two paths to fascism that
I want to avoid and the way to avoid it is to fix the system.
So number one path is >> people get so mad at the injustices
of this current corrupt system.
>> I mean you'd have to get really rude as to win here.
It's like, do you think it's weird to sort of normalize Dick
Fentes when he's way more charismatic and entertaining than you
and tell people that he kind of has a point? Do you think Do
you think that might be like a problem that could lead to something
bad happening, Chank? Do you think that's possible a little bit
anywhere in that brain anywhere?
Like he's way funnier than you. He's way more tapped in than
you. He's he's done more. No. No.
>> Say he's done more to stop Israel than you ever have.
>> You know, Fuentes direction and beyond Fuentes, right?
to whatever is beyond fuentes. And so at that point, if that
becomes popular enough because >> oh my god, I just I was
walking away to get some caffeine and then I heard that voice
crack. Oh my god,
>> system that they go in the you know Fuentes direction
and beyond Fuentes, right? To whatever is beyond Fuentes.
>> No, Jack. No. And so at that point if that becomes popular
enough because of suppression and that's what's happening now.
The Barry Weiss of the world are suppressed, suppressed, suppressed.
Don't let them breathe. Don't let them breathe. Right? And and
and so they're helping Fuentes and beyond Fuentes more than they
realize. So that's one path to fascism. The other path is the
path we're on now.
>> Hold on. Hold on. He just did a Fentes bit. Okay. He
just did a Fentes bit and it was so not funny in comparison.
It wasn't even close as good.
Let me breathe. I can't breathe.
Ben Shapiro, get your neck. Get your knee off my neck.
I can't breathe. Let a breathe.
It's
It's ridiculous.
Chang just did that. Barry Weiss, get your get your boot off
my neck.
Let me breathe. >> This is the like the establishment is
the path to fascism because what's going >> Wait, hold
on. Hold on. You heard it right. Let him do it again. >> Crumb
of power power will then align themselves with fascists. >> So
I think that there are two paths to fascism that I want to avoid.
And the way to avoid it is to fix the system. So number one path
is people get so mad at the injustices of this current corrupt
system that they go in the you know Fuentes direction and beyond
Fuentes right to whatever is beyond Fuentes and so at that point
if that becomes popular enough because of suppression and that's
what's happening now the Barry Weiss of the world are suppress
suppress suppress don't let them breathe don't let them breathe
right and and and so they're helping Fuentes and beyond Fuentes
more than they realize So, that's one path to fascism. The other
path is the path we're on now. >> This is the like the
establishment.
>> I like Chank, but holy that's uh
I I feel like
Oh, man. I like Chank, but I do feel like this is the definition
of useful idiot. Like, unfortunately, it's like the extreme the
most extreme example I've ever seen of useful idiot in my life.
I think it's it's kind of crazy. is the path to fascism because
what's going to happen next is Palanteer Palunteer tested all
their technology in Gaza. Now Larry Ellison and and the guys
at at Palanteer are saying you now know how to control a >> Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. Trank who?
Larry who?
>> Then you do this.
Okay, I didn't do the meme. I didn't do the meme. I'm just saying
this. Okay, this is the Larry Ellison. Hey, give me Tik Tok.
Work for Israel. Give me CBS. Work for Israel. Give me the American
>> Dude, I just h
God. The world is amazing. What an amazing world we live in sometimes.
Okay. It's so It's just so amazing
>> So, they're going to bring that here. If populists on
the right or left don't win or some sort of combination don't
win in 2028 then the Ellison's and the Peter Teals and and and
those guys the penalties are going to turn this current >> Dude
Shank is like dude it's amazing
>> Shank's doing things with anti-semitism that that up
until like six months ago seemed
hither to him dreamt of okay to quote the the Avengers. All right.
God, [clears throat] like he he just straight up did that. Now
he's like actually arguing these powerful Jews are are literally
going to take over the government if you don't vote for populist
in 2028. He's he's actually going all the way. He's going dude
like this kind of would have a year ago, two years ago, Fuentes
would have blushed to hear this be said. All right. Um actually
this filthy Larry Ellison is going to take over our government.
Okay. This filthy these filthy and lovers, Peter Teal, Larry
Ellison, they're going to take over the government. It's like
go tank. Whoa.
You You can't do that. Chank. Chank. I don't think you're allowed
to do that. Chank, you're on Twitch right now. Chank, please
chill the out. Oh, wait. Dude, I love that Twitch is like by
far the least anti-semitic platform and yet
and yet they get the worst rap. It's really unfortunate. >> into
a fascist establishment. >> Although Although I say that
I say that, but uh but here we have Ian Carol once again. 800
viewers today. Ian Carol over here on Twitch just doing his thing.
So maybe not the le not the least anti-semitic place anymore.
Not if Ian Carol's streaming.
I think well >> do you think do you think Ian Carol saw
some Dan Saltman tweets and was like, "Oh, Twitch sounds like
my kind of platform. Maybe I'll find some like-minded individuals
there."
>> I do see what you're saying. I think that we're already
there in many ways. I think that the new iteration like
the Republicans have already become a
is totally going to eat it up when JD Vance positions himself
as an America first populist in 2028, isn't he? I mean, he probably
eats that up now. JD Vance always has he's been positioning himself
as that since his uh rebrand under the Trump thing. Unless by
America first populist you mean like actual like open racist,
open anti-semite
while being a race mixer. I don't know. That seems like a weird
direction to go. It depends on what you mean by America first.
Like the Trump movement calls itself America first too. roll
and Donald Trump is doing that right now with the type of populism
that you're talking about
um with the sloppilism if you will where um liberalism has been
an abject failure and that's the reason why one of the two major
parties dude why do you also why do you say this liberalism has
been an abject success for anybody who lives under it for the
past like
100 years give or take liberalism's been amazing thing. Don't
say it's been an abject failure. You live in like the the temple
of the the peak of liberalism. It might not be working now. It
might be failing now, possibly, maybe not. But why do you no
>> is basically evolving beyond and the other one is always
in a consistent consiliatory
or conceding tone towards the other party that is is restructuring
itself as a fascist one. Um, and my point is that the normal
evolution beyond that normal evolution beyond that point would
be Tucker Carlson. I don't think JD Vance is going to lead the
Republican party in the future. I think I think it's going to
be the Tucker Carlson that leads the party. But do you think
Tucker Carlson is going to go in there and actually take out
Palunteer and and corporate capital? I don't I do not believe.
>> No, those are two different things. Two different things.
Palanteer and Corporate Capital are different. I don't think
I don't think Tucker Carlson does that at all. >> Look,
I don't know. I can't speak. >> You You do know. There's
every indication. Okay. Every single indication that Tucker is
for sale the highest bidder, that you can't trust his word, that
he has like totally reinvented himself. You literally do know.
You just don't care. You This is one of those things where like
you can convince Never try to convince somebody of something
that like their livelihood relies on, right? Is that the the
phrase? never try to convince somebody of of a fact that their
livelihood relies on them not understanding I think is is the
the the phrase right something like that like
relies with his whole like unaligned anarchisparian thing that
he him and an are both doing they rely on not
that's what they rely on so they're going they're making money
they're making a lot more money than they were just running as
like socialists
and now it's like well the people seem to want this the people
want us to hear everybody out the people the people the people.
They've offloaded their critical thinking to their audiences.
Not smart. Not a good Not a good idea. >> Speak for him
at all. But to me, what you're describing, I don't think that
the right-wing voters best exemplified probably by Tucker Carson,
and we agree with that, right? That he's probably the best avatar
for the right-wing voters,
>> I don't know if he's the best avatar. He is the
old person avatar and he's trying to adopt some of the younger
person beliefs. is I don't think they're fascists. I don't think
that they necessarily want to go towards fascism. I think they're
popular,
>> bro.
Chank.
Uh, I don't think they're fascist. I don't think they want to
go towards that fascism. Then why do they all support the fascist
takeover of your government? Why do they all support all the
fascist that's happening there? The total destruction of any
of the the processes that made your country like respectable.
the the actual like foundational pieces of your democracy like
your judges like trying to keep your judge apolitical your uh
judicial system apolitical. Why why is that something that has
gotten totally obliterated under Donald Trump and you're just
like yeah I don't think they're fascists. I don't think any of
them support fascism. They're literally supporting a transition
towards that right now. They're weakening all of the uh like
institutions that hold your country together. Very very bizarre.
I didn't do a good job of explaining that but I
They are undermining key tenants of a liberal democracy while
pretending not to. Right. Yes. Ignoring the courts, refusing
to acknowledge court orders, refusing to do stuff based on what
the court rules. Yes. Like they are consistent. And they're consistently
trying to get rulings that allow them to do this that let them
get away with
>> We can disagree about that. >> I think right-wing
populism is fascism. Right-wing populism is fascism in the most
like >> it doesn't have to be at all >> historically.
And you don't even know if they're what's the what's the difference?
So then Tucker Carlson's a >> So look here here I'll give
you >> he believes in free healthcare. He believes in Medicare
for all. He believes in uh you know uh everyone being able to
afford a home. >> No no you don't. Your two options aren't
fascist and socialist. Those are not your only options. >> Okay.
What's the what's the option for what does he want? >> So
for example Marjorie Taylor Green uh so she gets untethered from
corporate packs, right? So all of a sudden Epstein is real. But
then I our audience asked her, this is real, asked her to support
Roana's bill on lower drug prices and all of a sudden she supports
the bill on lower drug prices. Okay. So and then what does she
do? She's like, wait, the healthcare premium shouldn't double.
Right. So she's now headed was headed in that direction. Ideologically
in that direction. No, I got you. But so that's not a person
that was secretly fascist. that was not secretly heading in a
fascist direction. The more she opened her eyes to populism,
hold on. I I always asked this question and nobody ever ever
is honest about it for like four for like four to 10 years.
Does anybody think that it wasn't awesome to just be like a white
Aryan German? I'm sorry. I have to say this to people so they
can understand reality. like you went through the worst depression
in your country's history and then you had this massive meteoric
rise where you were like suddenly taking over Europe. Do you
think those people didn't love that while it was happening? Do
you think they didn't put a ton of principles to the side because
they were they were actually like working themselves into a wartime
economy? Everything was looking good, right? Their lives were
getting better in every measurable way. Do you not think so?
the the idea that a fascist wouldn't be okay with making things
better for the people. I would assume a as a prelude to fascism,
you would have to make things better for the people if you're
trying to transition from a democracy to some kind of autocracy,
right?
I say that in the most I say listen, I I do leave myself open
to being soundboarded there, but like realistically you have
to understand that they will try to make things better. They
will use the opices of making things better, the the promise
of making things better to get people on their side.
Trust me, I'm sure that 1937 Germans thought they were awesome.
They were on their way to the top of the world. Same with like
1940 Germans, okay? 1941 Germans. Guys, we just took over all
of Europe. We are the master. We're the best. Okay, that doesn't
mean the people being happy, the people being like taken care
of, it doesn't mean that everything's good. It doesn't mean Yeah.
It doesn't mean that like, oh,
they they couldn't possibly be fascist. they couldn't possibly
do things that work against the people's interest. So, I don't
know the idea that oh well Marjgery Taylor Green wanted to lower
drug prices. I'm sure wanted to lower drug prices. Okay. Not
that she's I'm just saying that it's not uh what do you call
it? Not exculpatory. It's not uh it doesn't prove it wrong. Okay.
>> The more she realized we agreed, right? So, instead
of saying no, I think you're a secret fascist and I'm gonna hate
you. What my point is, wait, maybe we should open our eyes together
and go, oh, we have a common enemy. The common enemy is the establishment.
Let's go get those sons of I think the common enemy and then
we'll have a democracy and then we'll see do people want to go
right or left and they don't have to go all the way to socialists
and they don't have to go all the way to fascists. They could
find a nice
>> place somewhere on the spectrum that is right for America.
Yeah. I
I guess I don't have the same level of confidence that you do
in uh any politician really cuz I it's not like I I have uh this
degree of confidence in even Democrats really. Uh but I certainly
do not have that for like the healthy skepticism and scrutiny
that I have for Democrats is even twofold if not 10fold for Republicans
who have uh spent their entire political careers uh harming the
working poor. >> So let me ask you the last question. So
I look I want someone on the populist left to win. Ro Kana, John
Stewart, someone along those lines, right? >> I don't So
I don't want Tucker and Marjorie Taylor Green to win. They're
on the right. So we don't agree on a b whole bunch of stuff and
some of the stuff that's really important >> like like
Marjorie Taylor Green is like, "Oh, why are we funding Ukraine
or Israel? We should be bombing Mexico instead." I think that's
ridiculous. >> So we can get into all that, but but >> Hank
wants to ignore all those things. Tank's willing to stack up
as many like totally unprincipled, unscrupulous allies as he
can to take over. And then he's like after people will decide
that I'm the leader of the people will decide that my ideas will
win. Just stacks up all of the least principled, most unscrupulous
like losers he can. Gets them on his side and is like, "Surely
the people who who all of the audiences who follow these people
like religiously will like me surely they'll see that I had the
best ideas."
>> I'm think is what I'm saying. insane thing to say. >> Okay,
but if you had to pick between Tucker and Marco Rubio,
right? Marco Rubio being more classic establishment uniform.
>> There's no I'm not voting for either. >> no. No.
I'm putting a gun to your head and you're going to [__]
>> unironically I'm getting pretty close to saying Rubio.
I listen, Marco Rubio is a horrific person,
but like honestly when when it comes to an ambigu unless you
have some actual proposal to make things better, unless I know
what your beliefs are, I'll be real
and I say I say this in a way that Cheng's audience and Fentes's
audience could understand. Okay? I
unless you have some plan to make things better, unless you actually
write out what your ideology is that you can help me understand
and you have like a plan and you're going in a direction and
you're willing to be out in the open with it without you know
all this
clo and dagger you're all getting up to, then give me the guy
who rolls with the cuz that's what I I made the wrong choice
in 2016 hypothetically. Okay, I had I had a choice between Trump
or Hillary. Give me status quo unless you can actually like elucidate
something. Unless you could actually like describe your ideas,
describe what you want. Cuz holy, I'm done. I'm done taking like
the ambiguity and saying, "Well, it couldn't possibly be worse."
Yes, it can. It can be worse. It can totally be worse. Okay.
It could totally be worse. Give me the status quo. Rather than
somebody who can just go, "Well, here's why everything's bad.
Sorry. >> President Rubio or Tucker, >> pull the
trigger. I'm dead anyway." Both will both if given
uh if given the opportunity both will [__] will end
me because this is like the this is no different than like well
you know gun to your head establishment Democrat versus establishment
Republican. They are both in the margins. The difference between
Tucker Carlson and Marco Rubio on some issues might actually
favor Tucker Carlson. Let's say he is genuine when he says uh
you know every American should own a house. What's going on?
Maybe he is real about that and he wants to solve the housing
crisis. Sure, that's good. But he might be more reactionary than
Marco Rubio, at least in the way that he's talked about things
when he saw his legacy Americans and that we have 65 million
immigrants that need to be deported, which happens to be the
number of Mexicans and and uh Latino people in this country,
right? The Hispanic population of this country.
Uh when has it ever happened that a populist coalition hasn't
tended to its natural extremes when in power for long enough?
No idea why Cheng thinks any form of moderate coalition would
emerge for from what he's proposing. Also, like do you just go
back to liberalism after or do you like populism just runs on
pointing out problems and not really having solutions?
So when that when you come in and you don't fix anything and
then I guess you just like increase taxes and walk away and then
let liberals go back at it or something. I don't even know.
I the thing with populism is it doesn't have like a steady state.
li maybe that might be why liberalis liberalism is good is it
seems to have some steady state it reaches like a status quo
there is some equilibrium with a populist movement there's no
such thing as that you you move forward in a direction okay you
just burn stuff up until there's nothing else to burn and sometimes
that leads to like something better coming out of the ashes but
why would you I don't know why you risk that right now >> country
so maybe [snorts] he might be >> well sorry I know why
Americans would risk that
I think they don't understand how much worse things can get.
Yeah. I think I think people just don't understand how much things
how much worse things can get. >> More reactionary than
Marco Rubio in terms of an initiative that designs concentration
camps. So the the surreal scenario that you're presenting is
technically no different than the harm reduction voting narratives
that the Democrats uh that push for as well. >> Then what's
the answer, brother? >> The answer is you continue organizing.
You continue building external pressure mechanisms whether it
be the union. >> That's what's happening right now. Exactly.
And >> and it's pressuring Tucker to go towards >> and
you continue. Okay, good. Then we keep fighting and then we keep
pushing Tucker further and further until he's running around
saying he's a socialist. He still would be a nationalist socialist,
but >> No, no, the problem super super last thing. The
problem is the you're worried they're going to turn into fascists
and start concentrating on
they're worried that you're communist. I think I think Tucker's
looking to seize power so he can like
get exposed in the Epstein files like 500,000 times.
Tucker Tucker is the [laughter] >> And you're going to
>> Tucker is like I feel like honest to God I swear I I
I know that this isn't true or I at least am aware that this
is conspiratorial thinking that's not supported by anything,
but in my mind Tucker is like the guy who's going to move forward,
take the reigns of this populist movement and then get exposed
as a so he can disgrace that movement. Okay. He's going to be
like the destiny of the populist movement. That's what he's trying
to do. Okay. >> Concentration camps. >> Whereas I'm
saying guys, >> who would I put in the concentration camps
if I were to make them? >> I don't want any piece of that.
So, >> I'm just saying. >> Okay. So, my point is
>> I'm blocking your guys. >> If the option is imprisoning
every
uh just in case Yogi is watching, that's a joke. Destiny's not
technic I'm not technically calling Destiny an actual Okay.
Lots of people do, but I'm not going to. Okay. He just he just
likes retaining trial. Okay. That's >> person in the country
versus imprisoning financial criminals, right? I think that uh
the overwhelming majority of Americans would go no. Yeah. Put
the bosses in jail as opposed to if that's the gun to your head
equation. I think >> but one in your hypothetical one is
literally criminals. Of course you put them in jail. Like what?
The white collar criminals are criminals. That's the reason.
But that's not a concentration camp. That's just enforcing the
law. >> So okay. So look, because you're both so worried
about communism and fascism, it's preventing you from working
together to topple your actual immediate present threat, which
is the establishment, which is going to wind up in fascism anyway.
So like, so Mike, let's topple them first. Get rid of the most
immediate fascist threat and and and team up with populism. So
if you put a gun to my head, I'm not saying I'm going to vote
for Tucker, period. No, I'm going to vote for someone on the
left, a left-wing populist. But gun to my head, Tucker or Rubio
or Ted Cruz? That's not close. I'll take my chances with Tucker
over Rubio and Cruz, which is certain oppression and disgusting
and also nationalist and the worst of the abuses. And >> yeah,
some say this is every single person within the right-wing populist
movement, BB Poison, that all of them
all of them are being allowed to grow and and make things of
themselves. Candace, Tucker, F because they all are going to
have like cataclysmic falls, >> corporatists, and and just
every terrible thing that you could imagine. I don't want the
status quo. I mean, I think I think voting for Tucker over Marco
Rubio, who would inevitably yield Tucker as the final evolution
of fascism, is basically jumping uh on the fascist line >> and
and you're making
I think Tucker Carlson is more of a I think Tucker Carlson is
more of a principal fascist than than uh even Marco Rubio is.
Marco Rubio is an establishment Republican that is responsible
for unimaginable amounts of violence all around the world. >> Who
wants to start the war in Venezuela? Rubio does not agree more.
Tucker Carlson outside Tucker Carlson outside of the confines
of establishment media now says he doesn't want a war with Venezuela.
I agree with you. Except when he had a crumb of power, when he
was within the confines of major media, Tucker Carlson was still
very much in favor of all the wars. What makes you think that
when he has a crumb of power, he's not going to snap back into
being a wonderful servant of the same capital owning mass. There
is the military-industrial complex that is demanding war with
Venezuela or Exxon and Chevron and numerous other industries
of extraction that want to >> Yeah, he he was sliding into
talking points there way too quickly talking about the military-industrial
complex. No, no, no, no, no. It's the oil companies in this case.
>> Take as much of the Venezuelan oil as possible without
any sort of government intervention. he would do the same exact
thing and be also worse when it comes to even and this is not
even an argument for Margot Rubio them both like I said kill
me instead but >> they're both the same side of the evil
fascist coin one is just more ideologically grounded in fascism
I >> and that is Tucker Carlson >> no the the most
irrational uh phrase we have in the English language is uh I'd
rather have the devil I know uh than the devil I don't know uh
and uh no that makes no sense. The devil I know I know is a devil.
I know Rubio and Cruz uh and all those guys are certain death
for democracy, certain death for the idea of America. And I and
we have to get off that road as soon as possible.
>> This is I you don't see this very often. This is this
is Chank falling into the same the exact same thing he did with
Hillary Clinton versus Bernie in uh
Like I will say Bernie energized people. It's pos possible that
Bernie should have been able to win and and get through the but
he was like so convinced that Bernie was better and Hillary was
evil and it's like okay but like Hillary was a known quantity.
She had governed a lot and you don't know what a Bernie Sanders
presidency would look like. Like it is a market departure. You
can't just say the unknown is better than what you have now.
You have to or at least you shouldn't say it like totally as
if it's obviously going to be better, right?
I'm sorry. You don't know that it's going to be better. In fact,
things could get so much worse basically every time. I'd say
with Tucker Carlson, that's like a hundred times more than what
happened with Bernie. At least Bernie seemed to be like a pretty
principled like guy who just stood on business and cared about
people. Like at least he had a long track record of being incredibly
consistent and having empathy and like human understanding and
caring about people.
Okay. Like that existed with Bernie. Cool. I think you can roll
with that and give him a lot of charity. Tucker is
he's like a known unknown. He is like a known like we know that
we can't know what he really wants.
He's a known untrustworthy individual. Like you are you are signing
on for like the dumbest thing I've ever heard of in my life.
Yeah. And now somebody pointed it out. I actually do have to
go find the Young Turks coverage of Tucker Carlson's Grocery
Trip. Hold on. Let me go find it. So, and you are making a whole
heap
>> Bernie also has a consistently track consistent track
record of losing
track record legis in legislation
losing. I mean, hold on one that's like saying because
dude that's like saying because you try to do ambitious stuff
in terms of legislation you are like useless. I don't think pushing
people I don't think like expanding the overton Bernie might
might not have been effective on his own but he was just like
a pre like a prelude a precursor to like the Democrat tea party
that's going to form around his ideas and push them left right
with the Overton window
like that that will happen more and more and more
like this idea of of pushing the Overton window of being that
person who's going to push things in that direction
um that
yeah I think that's never going Okay. So much has happened since
2016 because of him. Nope. But you need somebody. You need somebody
in the trenches. Okay. You need a tip of the spear. Bernie's
a the tip of the spear. Okay. And things Wait, hold on. There
are entire like grassroots organizing networks that exist now
because Bernie ran, right? I'd say a lot of tangible change yet.
No, but listen. We Everybody said, "Oh, Nick Fentes, that that
useless loser who like won't move off of this Israel question.
That guy is like totally he's a total joke. He's going to be
out of politics in 5 years, right?
Sometimes you just need somebody who's there who's saying the
things everybody needs to hear so that when they're proven right,
uh, everybody who believed in them can be like raised up and
I don't know. I I think there's like a lot to it. There's a ton
>> assumptions about Tucker and MTG. And hold on, maybe
you're right. Maybe you're right. And maybe you're not right.
The difference between Tucker Carlson and Nick Fuentes is that
Tucker Carlson is much more media trained after doing media for
as long as Nick Fuentes has been alive. So he doesn't he knows
what not to say. That's it. That's the big difference. >> All
right, that's your assumption. But for me, I have to partner
with populists on the right. Okay. >> Otherwise, we will
never ever ever defeat the establishment and we'll both be defeated
by them and they'll laugh their ass off at us. Right. So what
what form does that partnership take? I don't know. Again, I
don't I don't necessarily care about Tucker in general, but I
do care about his audience. And I think that he is leading them.
I guess in some ways he's leading them uh in an anti-Israel slant,
which is good. >> Yes, very much so. >> And whenever
he leans into
uh left populist sentiment, that's a good thing that his audience
is like, "Oh, I actually do agree with that. That is good." However,
I think he's doing that to win favor with people like yourself
and many others who are in the margins who go, "Why am I not
hearing this from uh any liberal in mainstream media? Why am
I only hearing this from Tucker Carlson? I kind of like him."
But I think his ultimate ambition is not that dissimilar from
whatever the Marco Rubio would do or whatever the uh Donald Trump
is doing currently. And I get agreement that if even >> man
I think uh I
>> I don't see how anybody could think Marco Rubio is like
principally committed to populism or principally committed to
almost anything
like like sorry anything in terms of the like pro
foundational American like the white identity stuff and he doesn't
even hint at that [__] Like I've never seen any of
that from Marco Rubio. For all I know, Marco Rubio is like, "Oh,
I guess I'll be Secretary of State because I want these people
not to hate me, and I think they're going to fall apart, but
I'll I'll try to keep things sane over here." Marco Rubio looks
like he wants to kill himself every single time he's on camera
with Trump speaking. Every single time, he looks like he is ready
to put a gun in his mouth.
So, I don't know. I don't know how to I don't know how to understand
that or interpret it. It's very crazy. Yeah, he seems like a
neocon, but I I don't see how he's like at all like the the fascist
type people, unless you want to say all the neocons are fascists,
but
but like the Bushes never attack. Well, there was a Supreme Court
ruling once. Certainly not more than fascism light. >> even
if it's a ruse, if he helps stop the genocide, that that is a
[laughter]
>> good thing and and would never be by the Rubios and
the Cruzes of the world. So like can we take that win
isolated by itself? >> But I don't think he would do that
is my >> But he's going to try he's trying to end the genocide
now. >> I know. But I think if he was in a position of
power and not like um if he cuz when he was >> but when
he was forget the hypothetical
I'm not even talking about when he was at Fox News he was pro
all of America's wars. That's when he had a a a closeness to
to real power and uh and he was again a servant of capital but
more directly and in that moment that was what Tucker Carlson
was doing. There is no indication that if he actually came to
real political power uh that he would he would do anything different
than still serve the interests of capital as he has his entire
career. If if somebody like Tucker, MTG or Massie doesn't win
on the right and someone like Ro Kana, John Stewart, Nina Turner
doesn't win on the
uh then we're in a world of trouble and there is there's no that
path is super
>> So to me, I'd rather take populist on both sides and
see which I mean the
>> son's only correct in that he I feel like son's correct
for the wrong reasons, too. I feel like his read of like Rubio
like that's that's a totally wrong read. He happens to be right
and you should maybe vote for Rubio over Tucker because Tucker
is like
I don't know. Tucker at best at best is like an incredibly um
is just an incredibly good grifter who knows how to make money
at worst is like an actual foreign asset.
Yeah. I don't know. It sounds like correct but he's like his
read of Rubio is like fascist coded. It's just very bizarre to
me. dream is populist on both sides. Let's go to an election
and see if the country wants to go populist left or right. >> Literally,
you are relitigating. >> But Trump is an obvious fake populist.
>> Okay. But but that's my point. That's the most obvious
obvious fake populist. He ran as a real populist. >> I
got you. I got you. But Trump didn't do anything that So like
for example, right now Tucker says, "End the genocide. End the
funding of Israel." Trump never did anything real like that.
>> No. Except [clears throat] Tucker is saying that because
he is no longer
in the same rooms as he once used to be. >> Good. Wonderful.
He's not in those >> I know. But but if he were to actually
>> is it possible he's changed multiple times? No, not
really. I mean, or like it is, but then if he's that changeable,
then yeah, it's possible he'll change back. That's pretty scary.
That's the That's the problem, Chank. If he's changed like that
much that many times, well, he could just change back. I don't
think it I don't think he actually had a genuine change of heart.
I don't believe that at all. Um but it doesn't even matter to
me whether he had a genuine change of heart. I care about his
output because he's a media figure. And on that front, I'm I'm
glad that he is anti-Israel. Okay. Having >> Yeah. But
we don't call this it's not fascism. Would you do it elsewhere?
Canadian caller. Okay. That's just called uh America. It's called
America. Okay. Back in the neocon days, we used to bomb brown
people. We're going to bomb brown people again.
tell you what >> said that. I think that the real reason
why he's doing that is because he has to read the room and he
no longer he no longer has a >> bomb. Hey guys, it turns
out we could bomb brown people on our continent on our our land
mass. Okay,
we didn't even have to go to the Middle East. We can BOMB THEM
IN SOUTH AMERICA for oil. We we bomb them. We get oil. We we
can't just replay the whole thing. Oh my god. higher priority
of being a servant of capital at least for now until he gets
to a position of power at which point I think he would still
advance the same exact agenda that Donald Trump did. Wait, why?
Why would you brown why would you bomb brown people under Fuentes?
Only he's mute. Did Donald Trump came in with the exact same
sentiment? Adjust. >> You think Tucker is going to work
for Israel like Trump is? >> Absolutely. No way. >> I
I do think if Tucker Carlson >> Oh, that is the very last
thing. >> Bernie Sanders would also uh not be an anti-imperialist
if he came into a position of power. I think as it stands currently
without external pressure mechanisms that make it a non-starter
and that's changing and this in the environment is changing uh
dramatically right now you are never going to have a a real anti-imperialist
figure a real like anti-Israel figure that is is capable of decoupling
America from that's sorry it's like a different thing
just just to be clear I think it's a way different thing I think
it's like we bomb South America and nationalize their oil for
US as opposed to we bomb South America, nationalize their or
oil or or corporatize their oil for Exxon Mobile, right? It's
like a different thing. But when I said that the right-wing might
come towards us on Israel, people said, "You're nuts. That's
not going to happen." And it did happen. So my point isn't rah
me. My point is maybe we should be a little bit more open. And
maybe it could happen on another issue and another issue and
maybe we can work together to actually end the funding of >> those
people are are coming to terms with this because of the endless
amounts of the endless amounts of pressure from the wokes the
wokes that were jailed
uh under the the Biden administration. 3,500
student protesters were thrown in jail for protesting against
Israel, for example. It's the wokes that are unironically carrying
this conversation paired up with a barrage of of pain and violence
that people actually saw all over their social media feeds and
and that is the reason why a lot of uh a lot of people inevitably
came to that conclusion and realized that paired up with Israel's
arrogance as well uh and endless demands for control and endless
demands for feelalty. Um, but ultimately, like I said, that was
an external pressure point that actually caused a lot of people,
a lot of voters to finally come to that conclusion as well. So,
it's um the the conversation that we're having still has to be
uh about continuing to to build external pressure like uh external
pressure movements and and
not care about Tucker Carlson necessarily, but care about winning
and convincing Tucker Carlson's audience just like not caring
about the Republican party in general, but instead caring about
convincing the Republican voters. And the only way to do that,
and I think you and I agree with this on this, is by offering
them something. Housing, health care, uh an an end to corporate
corruption in this country. These are the things that we can
actually win uh uh the attention and the loyalty of the right
on right-wing voters on uh without having to concede on any of
the social issues whatsoever.
>> Yeah. Let's send on agreement. Yeah. and my daughter's
doing this to me on uh about dinner. Anyway, everybody, God bless,
man. Hey, happy Thanksgiving, >> This was a much more uh
agreeable Thanksgiving, ladies and gentlemen. You got to flex
for the camera for for uh for the purpose of you do it every
year
for the for the purpose of continuation.
Here it is. >> I just wanted to see the uh Oh,
where I got There we go.
Wait, he doesn't flex. flex every year. Wait, none of these are
him flexing. There's only one.
There's only one of him flexing. What the [__] is
>> See you tomorrow.
Uh, I'll be back
as
>> That's it for Thanksgiving.